und
Die ersten leute sind auch schon am start
hoffe heute knackst das mikro nicht weil ich habe keine ahnung woran das gelegen haben könnte
Keine knack so ja die kam ja auch nicht immer
Die waren ja random irgendwie ich weiß auch nicht woran das geknackst liegt
Vielleicht
Vielleicht gibt auch wirklich meine verlängerung den geist auf ich habe ja seit
Mal zeigen ich habe seit ohne scheiß ich habe seit 20 jahren oder so
ein spaß
Ich habe seit 20 jahren oder so die gleiche verlängerung für das headset
beziehungsweise für das für das
Ja doch war damals auch ein headset guck mal das war noch ein microsoft sidewinder
Headset
Ja kennt dieses ding zufällig noch jemand also übelste schrott headset
Richtiger schrott ja aber dieses verlängerungs ding benutze ich heute noch
Und der einzige grund warum ich das mache ist weil es einen physischen mute button hat
Sesc 838 dankeschön für den zapp oder seh
Es sie es das lied speak irgendwas ne wahrscheinlich nicht
Daher kommt das knackst du meinst es kann schon sein
Also ich habe dieses teile diese verlängerung habe ich schon seit 20 jahren oder so am start ich wir können mal gucken wie alt das ist
Release date wann kam das raus nein never never
Das ist schwachsinn hat seine controller
Wir gucken einfach mal nach einem review seit winder wie ist das game voice
Review wir gucken einfach mal nach einem nach einem review dann wissen wir anders wann das rausgekommen ist
2004 das ist auch eigentlich
Zu spät hier 2001 ja ja das
Das kommt ungefähr hin das kommt ungefähr hin also ich habe diese headset verlängerung seit 22 jahren
Und die geht immer noch
Also das headset ist das headset hat wirklich schon lange den geist aufgegeben aber diese verlängerung mit dem mute button so die benutze ich
heute noch
22 jahre headset verlängerung
Mal gucken wie war denn damals der test
Mit der hardware ist es microsoft gelungen ein sehr gutes produkt für gamer zu veröffentlichen ja
Battlecom oder roger willkommen das verwendet niemand mehr
Kommt man damals hat man sich über 100 mark für den headset beschwert naja gut
Das hat damals dass die software hatte damals text to speech und die war richtig mies im vergleich zu den dingern die man heute
so heute so kennt
Ja
Wie gesagt die headset verlängerung habe ich immer noch am start
Retro hardware mit mind factory hat sowas noch da weiß ich dass ich alt bin
Da weiß ich dass ich alt bin wenn ich im retro review was sehe was ich damals neu gekauft habe
Ja oh man und chat was so bei euch heute passiert
Ich kann euch noch was lustiges erzählen mich hat letztens auf der arbeit jemand gefragt hatten wir teams call und
Auf einmal fragt wenn ich so gefragt so bildschirm scheren und sowas auf einmal fragt er mich so sag mal max warum copy paste ist
Du immer einsen hinten am text
Und ich wollte ihm eigentlich instinktiv sagen machen wir ausrufezeichen 1 in chat aber
Ist mir eingefallen wir sind hier nicht im high IQ twitch chat aber ihr seid nicht die einzigen die das festgestellt haben
Aber eigentlich noch für später paar spannende videos haben wir hier
Wir bauen einen server in berliner rechenseite ach hier der aua wir wollen ja das video angucken woraber eins und eins gewesen ist
Ja auf dieses comment wird er bestimmt antworten und sagen ja jonteske schick mal her
Jonteske schick mal her
Je nachdem was es ist vielleicht doch ja
Ja nix spannendes oder also heute
War auch recht recht entspannend
Ja das kommen wir nachher heute war echt recht entspannend ich habe heute tatsächlich außer der reihe nach das wäre mir beim alten arbeitgeber
wahrscheinlich nie eingefallen
Aus der reihe mal noch kurz auf meeting gejoined auf der arbeit
15 uhr
Obwohl ich heute eigentlich nicht da bin muss ich morgen gleich in die zeit erfassung eintragen und dann bin ich mal gespannt
Was die zeit erfassung macht
Ob die zeit erfassung dann sagt das ist kein freier tag und rechnet es komisch ab weil dann mache ich das nie wieder
Oder
Oder also ich gehe davon aus dass es funktioniert weil
Ich habe ja am montag habe ich ja null sollstunden das heißt alles was ich dort mache ist dann auch immer automatisch
Automatisch plus so ich muss mich gerade mal eine runde beruhigen mit paar fischen
Also wir können mal kurz package updates machen weil artsch bei the way rolling release
Was gibt es denn für updates schätzt mei
Licenses
Javascript wird geupdated javascript stells jeden tag 5 gigabyte updates
Ja artsch die looks muss man halt manchmal leiden
Ob man nicht drumherum dafür hat man die beste distribution ever
Gibt es eigentlich gute zeit erfassung system oder sehen die alle so aus wie
1995 und die sehen alle aus wie 1995 also alle die ich kenne
Also eines der hässlichsten zeit erfassung systeme ist das hier interflex zeit erfassung das musste ich jetzt
Das muss ich jetzt auch schon ein paar mal benutzen
So modern sieht das nicht aus
Ja schon besser ja so sieht so sieht das login aus ungefähr
Ja
Aber aber wenn ich ich das ist das ist das ist zu modern das so sieht nicht so
So sieht das nicht aus so sieht es aus
Probe Maria
So sieht das aus
Ja, ja genau
Genau so sieht es aus probe maria
Was moment was öffne ich hier jetzt gerade gut dass wir unter linux sind
Ah
elektronische zeit erfassung an den schulen südtirols gut dass dass wir das mal
Dass dass das mal gesehen habe jetzt wie das da aussieht ja genau so so sieht die zeit erfassung aus die ich meine
Die muss ich jahrelang benutzen dass das wirklich
Das ist wirklich hier 1995 hat angerufen
Genauso sieht das aus
Css wozu wer braucht css
Css komplett overrated outdated gebetet genau so sieht es aus ja ja
Alles zeit erfassung ist die dinge also wie gesagt
Ist das probe maria hier also an der stelle wo ich sage ich kenne keine zeit erfassung die wirklich gut aussieht
Heuss x moment das muss ich mir jetzt angucken dass das sieht das hört sich nicht nach die bade porn an dass ich jetzt aussehen das
falsche aufmache
Heuss x das ist irgendwas anderes zeit
zeit erfassung
zeit heuss x zeit erfassung
Soll ja auch nur zeiten erfassen ja gerade deswegen könnte man das optisch ganz gut machen da ist ja keine großartige
Komplexität im ui ich denke mal im background ist so eine zeit erfassung nicht nicht so unterschöpft zu zu unterschätzen aber
kann das durchaus
ist
Guse
Okay gucken wir uns mal ein paar bilder von an okay das sieht old school aus
Das sieht aus als hat einer versucht im im browser windows 98 nachzumachen
Moment ist das überhaupt im browser
Ja das ist ein browser sieht aus der axel fichter ist am start
Ja sie wirklich außerzeit einer im browser windows 98 nachmachen wollen
aha
Das ist mir neu also damit hatte ich
What the fuck bin ich hier sehend
Was ist das pdf ausgabe 32 iskos news
Wo sind wir hier gelandet chat wo habt ihr mich hier?
persönlicher kalender
Sieht das schlecht aus
Outlook
Outlook kann einpacken wobei ich ja persönlich auch nicht gerne outlook benutze aber ich weiß immerhin funktioniert das halbwegs
iskos
Ja sieht super modern high end aus
Also bei uns auf der arbeit ist es irgendeine
Eigenentwicklung was auch sonst gepaart mit excel tabellen für irgendwelche anwesenheitsplanung ganz ganz wir aber
Letztendlich ich sag's doch immer wie es ist also ich sage ich doch immer wie ich wie ich denke dass es ist und zwar
excel ist die idee der sekretärin der sekretär innen muss man heute sagen
Es klingelt leute amazone ist da sec
so wieder da
es war amazon
Aber ich muss nicht selbst runtergehen
Die musik ist ein bisschen laut gerade muss man ein bisschen leiser machen
p und i loga 3 ok zeigt mal her
Wir raten jetzt eure zeiterfassung
soll das wirklich von
Soll das wirklich erreichbar sein die webseite von außen
Okay, das sieht ja auch zum fürchten aus aber aber immerhin ich meine es sieht ein bisschen aus wie
die 2008 wenigstens schon
das
Das habe ich schon mal gehört es kann sogar sein dass ich das kenne
Ich glaube das hatten wir beim provider das kommt mir übelst bekannt vor
Athos zeiterfassung
Der name kommt mir mega bekannt vor
Ja, aber das sah nicht so modern damals aus oder das sei das das muss das sah früher bestimmt viel älter und hässlicher aus
Ja, sowas in der richtung eher
hat das
Mittlerweile viel besser aus noch besser
Rotheim
Ich bin ich bin über staunen chat wie viel unterschiedliche zeiterfassung es gibt man würde ja eigentlich vermuten das thema zeiterfassung
ist jetzt
Nichts wo sich irgendwie 50 verschiedene anbieter behaupten können das ist ein recht überschaubares thema sollte man meinen
Ist es aber anscheinend nicht anscheinend gibt es da 100.000 anbieter sap hat doch bestimmt auch so was oder
Moment leute wir müssen jetzt mal kurz eine runde monka essen
Natürlich hat sap sowas
Und es sieht typisch beschissen aus wie ich mir vorstelle für sap
Was das schon wieder
Das garantiert aber das sind hier oben das sind open source icons hier das sind die die ich habe vergessen wie sie heißen die
Tango items weiß ich das sind die die normalen nur nach 15 open source icons
sap ist auch so ein ding wo ich mir immer denke das ist auch nur gemacht worden dass
consultants richtig viel geld kassieren können
Ich verstehe gar nicht ich weiß nicht wechseln die also mein letzter arbeitgeber hat seit ich da bin das gleiche hässliche zeiterfassung system gehabt
und
Die haben auch keine um keine keine anstalten gemacht das
Umzustellen
Also wir haben jetzt relativ viel zeit falls irgendjemand
Bock hat auf 1 2 stellen anzeigen angucken das streue ich ja immer ganz gern mal so zwischendurch ein dann schickt ruhig her
Wir können uns da heute schon so 1 2 3 angucken post champ
Und da gucken wir vielleicht schaffen wir es heute endlich
Ich wollte mir noch schon lange mit euch mal diesen konferenz talk hier angucken
Wenn ich ihn finde
Da geht halt 45 minuten
Und ihr wisst wenn ich in 45 minuten video gucke dann dauert das mal locker eineinhalb stunden
personio
Okay, die haben aber echt die chance verpasst person punkt io zu machen oder
Logge ich will ja loggen so ich will images suchen
Warum ist google teilweise so merkt wenn manchmal geht es mit images manchmal nicht
Zeiterfassung wie sieht es aus
Wait a minute das sieht ja
Das das sieht ja halbwegs modern aus was ist denn da los
Chat was meint ihr was die für einen css framework verwenden
Irgendwie kommt mir die kombination aus button button styling und so bekannt vor
Aber es kann auch sein dass die schlichten ergreifen das selbst gemacht haben weil so komplex ist das was man hier sieht jetzt ja auch
Nicht das ist sehr sehr
light css paar bunte buttons ein bisschen gestaltete tabelle
Die haben personen.io gesichert ja beste
Aber die haben abgelaufen das srl zertifikat
ins batman
So rebooten wir mal package up warum läuft da pearl achso
wegen aquarium
Moment die firma heißt ernsthaft
Css das blöder name
Wie viele zeiterfassung gibt es eigentlich das hört ja sie heißen ernsthaft css das das hört ja gar nicht mehr auf
Okay alter 1995 hat bescheid gesagt guckt euch das mal an what the fuck was ist das
Patrick dankeschön für den für den sub
Können wir endlich narrow people sehr ja wenn ihr mir den 7tv link schickst mache ich es rein
Das habe die alten am moment die neue sieht besser aus
Ja, okay stimmt die neue sieht tatsächlich besser aus aber als erste was man findet ist das hier wie sieht es eigentlich aktuell
Ich muss gerade mal das aktuelle
das aktuelle ranking mir angucken von
Auf browser starten
Chat mein browser ist kaputt
Firefox ist brocken
Ach okay ich habe nichts gesagt geht wieder ja was auch was auch immer
Kack bei firefox wie sieht es wie sieht es aktuelle textual ranking eigentlich aus
Hitliste lotus notes genau dahin wo es verdient
Ich ja das wundert mich warum gibt es so viele zeiterfassung systeme wie gesagt
Ich hätte gedacht es gibt so fünf große und paar kleine aber das war es gibt ja hunderte
Und jeder hat irgendwas anderes wahnsinn
Man würde man würde denken zeiterfassung ist irgendwie so gelöstes problem gibt es halt ein paar fertige
Ändert sich ja auch nichts es ist jetzt nicht so als würde zeiterfassung einmal im jahr komplett neu gemacht werden
Ja jeder macht ich glaube auch jede software klische die meint sie muss irgendwas auf sie muss irgendwas anbieten macht zeiterfassung system
Das ist ja auch easy
Das ist das ist vielleicht das ist wirklich das könnte echt so sein wie du sagst magst das ist die to do das ist die
to do app der neu gegründeten software
häuser
unternehmen
Ich weiß dann ob das so kompliziert ist zeiterfassung system zu bauen
Der fehler liegt da sicherlich auch im detail aber ich stelle es mir jetzt so krass kompliziert vor
Leute ihr werdet übrigens nicht glauben was ich heute gemacht habe
Ich habe weitergebaut am fiat champ
der kriegt jetzt ein webinterface
Ich habe heute mal ein neues projekt erstellt alles eingerichtet was webinterface backend angeht und ich habe sogar schon
angefangen die
das login und so
Mal ordentlich zu überarbeiten so dass man mehrere accounts gleichzeitig machen kann ist jetzt ein das ist nicht in rast
Ich habe es euch gesagt der chat kann so viel abstimmen wie er will ich rewrite ist nicht in rast
Das gab ja letztens sogar eine umfrage
Aber wie schon gesagt leute
Wenn einer von euch oder mehrere leute von euch mehrere agile progress das gerne in rast rewriten wollen das ist kein problem
Dann machen wir das so ich baue die ich baue die app einfach in dort net und ihr portiert das dann immer wieder auf rast
Dann dann bin ich dabei dann können wir eine alternative rast aber ich werde die rast version nicht programmieren
So viel kann ich rewrite fork champ ja fork moment wie sieht es denn eigentlich aus wir hatten eigentlich schon alles gefragt hier
Network ja wer hat hier gefolgt komm mal da wo bloß master ist da
Der max hat gefolgt irgendwann mal aber das ist
ne
Redesign
Ach hier das ist für die für die readme
Was ich nicht wollte wegen irgendwas weiß ich nicht mehr so julian hat
hat geupdated cyber dns hat geupdated
Entity naming
Entity naming asia asia pipeline da wollte es aber einer richtig wissen hier richtig agile champs am start
agile champ
.net desktop jammel repositorium geht haben tatsächlich paar leuten was daran rumgewürstet
Aber wie man hier sieht komplett fehlerfrei gibt keine bugs
First try
Es gibt kein nein oder
Kann man gar nicht auswählen
Ich glaube man kann bei twitch auch bloß
Mehr geht nicht oder mehr als fünf gibt es einen automatischen .net zu rast converter
Chat warum jetzt jetzt okay meine ernst gemeinte frage
Übrigens beide way nachdem der stream jetzt richtig angelaufen ist
Bevor wir bevor wir videos angucken und sowas wenn ihr noch 1 2 3 stellen anzeigen habt schickt es her ich bin heute in
stellen anzeigen stimmung
Kann auch durchaus mal was für azubi stellen oder sowas sein
Jetzt jetzt meine ernst gemeinte frage chat
Was versprecht ihr euch?
Unabhängig davon dass ihr zugucken könnt und sehen könnt wie es verkacke
Was würdet ihr euch von einem rast rewrite versprechen und jetzt sagt nicht blazing die fast weil das ist vollkommen egal in dem fall
Und es ist nicht so als wäre das aspeed und ein core back end irgendwie wahnsinnig langsam das ist okay
Dann müsste ich eigentlich rewriten jetzt hier ups zwei sie war ich angeklickt habe okay war mal gleich
Mach mal eine umfrage rewrite in c++
Mach eine umfrage rewrite in c++ oder rast machen umfrage was die leute mehr wollen rewrite in c++ oder rast
Ich
Weiß es wird beides es wird beides nicht passieren kann ich euch sagen
Okay meinetwegen macht bescheuert die bescheuerten sprachen rein ja
Okay, jetzt bin ich gespannt
rast rewrite subcode nein keine chance du könntest jetzt selbst 40 50 subs spenden ich würde es nicht rewriten in rast
Und ich muss das sagen weil wenn ich so just for fun sage 40 subs und ich rewrite es dann kommen die leute und machen das
noch oder muss ich das da muss ich
Fangen wir gar nicht erst an
Nein, gar nicht ich rewrite es nicht in rast
Okay, close close call hier c++ oder rast
Da haben die leute wieder irgendwelche sterne rein nicht sterne cute points reingehauen
C++ hat gewonnen weil ich meine bei 170 zuschauer
427 374 abstimmungen sind vielleicht leicht unrealistisch also ich sehe c++ rewrite
Ja schade dass es in c++ gar nicht möglich ist zu rewriten weil c++ in der standard library gar keine netzwerkgeschichten drin hat
tja
Da kann man wohl nichts machen
Wie
C++ hat mittlerweile einen webserver oder sowas eingebaut oder oder ein http client moment hat c++ wirklich ein http client
ach boost
Http client aber die haben die haben doch kein standard library
Http client oder nee haben sie nicht
Hätte mich jetzt auch sehr gewundert
Das boot das boost sowas hat das wundert mich nicht boost hat ja auch alles nur erdenkliche und egal wie unsinnig es ist
Ach ja stimmt sockets sockets hat es aber wahrscheinlich auch nur weil du c header inkluden kannst oder
Nee dass das wäre auch das wäre einfach zu useful die machen lieber passt mal auf c++
Die machen lieber
Gibt es eigentlich schon c++ 24
Oder ne das kommt alle wann kommt der c++ standard kommt der alle zwei oder alle drei oder
jahre
c++ new versions
intervall
Ist es ist es 2026 alle drei jahre ok
Lass mal passt mal auf jetzt guckt euch guckt euch das elend mal an
Neue features in c++
c++ 23 also
Erste am moment war das ist das ist alles da geht ja ich ich checke also es gibt standard float
Also da hat die welt anscheinend darauf gewartet weil obviously konnte man in c++ noch keine zahlen mit komma darstellen wichtig
standard float
was
bfloat
Sagt mir irgendeine andere sprache die einen typ bfloat 16 kennt
Standard flow alles klar
New language features gibt es nicht oder wie
bfloat 16 ja new feat wikipedia
What the fuck guckt euch mal den artikel anders in 5000 zeilen
nur für die ok was gibt es tolles neues in c++
Also was hat was haben wir denn hier schönes die wikipedia seite ist genauso schön unübersichtlich wie c++ selber
Gibt es da gibt es eine schöne schöne übersicht vielleicht
c++ ist finalized
mehr kek emotes
Echt genug also was haben wir denn neues hier wie wäre es mit einem beispiel gibt es da vielleicht ein ordentliches
das wikipedia
Examples sample new feature examples braumer get ready for c++ 23
Warte mal leute ich bin gleich wieder da
Ich bin ich muss meiner katze mal ein bisschen medizin verabreichen ich bin in zwölf minuten wieder da
Ja chico will nicht so richtig
Wieder da okay
Das war ein größerer akt heute er
Chico wollte nicht chico muss
Was für die schilddrüse nehmen und chico muss was für die nieren checkt chico ist alt
Sie ist jetzt nicht super krank oder so er muss aber alles von den von den blutwerten und so im rahmen bleiben und die markt
das zeug für die für die niere nicht
Da stellt sie sich immer an
Manchmal müssen wir dazu zweithalten
Nein nein so schlimm ist es nicht passiert nichts
Chico ist ziemlich fit für ihr alter
Einfach zäpfchen ja klar
Easy zäpfchen ich glaube mit zäpfchen hätte ich bei chico noch mehr probleme
So also wo sind wir wo sind wir stehen geblieben
Benutzt du eigentlich im alltag avk hat mir das jetzt mal ein bisschen angeeignet ja aber ich benutze avk nur für super super simple geschichten also für
Was ich avk benutze ist zum beispiel keine ahnung
Hier was das ich wäre es eingeloggt ja wer ist eingeloggt und dann sage ich hier avk
Ich habe so hier print
Eins und so was ja so sowas sowas mache ich da
Grab nach fängt fängt an mit max und dann das zweite oder dritte feld ja mit
Sowas super komplizierte avk scripts baue ich nicht
Wobei man vieles auch tatsächlich ganz gut ohne avk lösen kann ja sowas hier könnte man zum beispiel auch mit dem
Delimiter irgendwie machen kat
Nur kat an space ist halt je nachdem wenn die anwendung
Spaces oder taps unterschiedlich hat nicht so ganz einfach also naja
Aber ja ich verwende avk relativ oft
Ah ja c++ feature sind wir gewesen genau also zeigt doch zeigt doch mal hier was was ist denn was ist denn schönes tolles
Tolles neues es gibt ja gar keine übersicht
C++ guck mal neun mal die offizielle c++ referenz hat eine gescheite übersicht
Gut unterstützen tun die compiler prinzipiell nur das worauf sie bock haben
Und wenn ich mir wikipedia angucke dann habe ich hier so eine
Und wenn ich mir wikipedia angucke dann stelle ich schon gleich fest
Wenn ich mir wikipedia angucke dann stelle ich mir gleich fest dass ich allein schon dort auf wikipedia nicht checke um was es geht was wollen
Die hier von mir so also guck mal was gibt was gibt es tolles neues static operator
Dings array alles klar keine ahnung. Oh c++ 26
Standard get ja da hat die welt drauf gewartet standard float standard get
Endlich
Narrow people
The emote is not publicly listed
big developments
Static operator
Okay
Leute die syntax ist so hässlich ich
ich mein
soll
Ist das ist das dafür gemacht dass irgendjemand wenn er es liest versteht was dort passiert
Static konstanz okay das ist irgendwas compile time mäßiges
Standard operator die ist das operator overloading oder was ist das
Ich weiß nicht mal was es sein soll
Ist es public jetzt
Wir frisch mal
Ja, nee nicht public
So dann haben wir als nächstes tolles feature noch ist das ist das so eine art
Ist das ist das so eine art pattern matching oder
Ist das so eine art pattern matching für c++
Nur dass sie die mit abstand hässlichste syntax ever genommen haben für so was wie pattern matching
Ich verstehe was es sein soll okay
Konst
Standard vector int und was auch immer was macht ihr denn und an der stelle c++ checkermans
C++ checkermans warum ist hier ein und an der stelle
Was soll das da warum ist das syntaktisch überhaupt korrekt?
Nee, das ist keine referenz
Oder moment moment warum ist es ein und und warum ist es kein sternchen
Was ist das überhaupt ist das ein return type von der funktion
Konst
get
Konst was ist der unterschied zwischen der referenz und dem pointer weil den pointer selbst als referenz zurück gibst
Was ist der unterschied zu einem pointer zurück zu geben ach das ist sowas mit ownership oder sowas
Aber warum ist es doppelt ach ist es ach jetzt check ich das oh gott die syntax ist so hässlich
Jetzt check ich das das ist okay jetzt jetzt kann ich euch glaube ich erklären das ist eine funktion
Mit dem namen get die als return type ein konst eine eine konst standard vector
int-referenz zurückgibt
Was das was macht das konst an der stelle ist jetzt ja die eigentliche frage
Also bis hierhin check ich es ja noch aber was macht das da
Das was sagt mir das an dieser stelle
Da habe ich jetzt gar keine idee was das sein soll
Objekt wird durch die funktion nicht verändert
Das sagt dass die
das get data nicht manipuliert
Ist das nur so sache wie also ist wird das entforst vom compiler oder ist das nur so eine anzeigesache
standard print
Warum nicht einfach das c print verwenden wenn man es braucht
Verwenden wenn man es braucht
Oder warum nicht standardformat was jetzt seit einer weile schon in c++ drin ist und eigentlich ganz gut ist
Also, okay, wenn ich das sehe muss ich ganz hartmonka schenken
Was okay, okay
Ich
Entdecken entdecken ist es ist das callback oder so was ist das essig wait ohne essig wait oder was
Da bin ich zu low iq für
okay
Ich höre jetzt auf mit c++ anzukommen
Chat ich glaube es wird mal wieder zeit für den c++ 23 stream oder
So aber ich wollte mir die stellen anzeigen mit euch angucken zusammen. Okay, wen haben wir step stone?
Also beziehungsweise step stone ist so ein portal
Wir hatten das gepostet
kurz chat gesuchen
So lange her dass nicht mehr meine history drin ist
Okay, also, wen haben wir denn hier?
wir haben die
mbda deutschland
it administrator
DevOps männlich weiß deutsch weiterentwicklung von container plattformen aha
Mr. Braul bist du noch am start
Also da gucken wir uns das ganze mal an ich ja ich bin super interessiert gebär
Wollte nur gucken was passiert
Bla bla resident sleeper time
Die bauen raketen für die bundeswehr
Was was die machen wäre mir fast egal so in der containerisierung
Weil man die raketen ja nichts zu tun kümmert sich um container plattformen die meiner bestimmt nicht container raketen
Geht es jetzt? Okay, ich gucke mal
Nein, aber es steht da dass dass du es verwendest
Jetzt geht's alles klar jetzt geht's
Jetzt geht's jetzt haben wir quasi
white people happy und
Was soll mir das sagen chanel, oh ja link kaputt, okay
Ach das wir haben so viele keki mods kek pyramide brauchen wir jetzt nicht auch noch
Kek
Ja, wir haben schon den würfel das muss reichen
Okay, so also da lasst uns das ganze noch mal anschauen
gut, also das erste was ich sehe ist die übliche
selbst lobpreisung
Da ist so fliege bei deinem mic macht machts geräusche wieder oder wie im hintergrund
Bla bla test test ja ich glaube meine weit meine verlängerung gibt wirklich langsam den geist auf
bla bla test test ja ich glaube meine
Vielleicht kann durchaus sein dass ich eine mücke hab
Also als führendes deutsches system aus der luftverteidigung
Lenkflugkörper und laser technologie keder werden raketen gebaut
Ja da gibt sicherlich welche die ihnen ist das nix die wollen da nicht arbeiten
Muss euch ehrlich sagen wenn die arbeit interessant wäre bzw. Wenn die bezahlung gut wäre
hätte ich da jetzt wenig Probleme mit. Ich meine, ich arbeite, ich habe auch jahrelang in der
Finanzbranche gearbeitet, wo im Außendienst irgendwelchen Leuten Sachen verkauft wurden,
die sie nicht brauchen. Also insofern, das ist bei mir eh durch. So, bla bla bla bla bla,
das ist im Prinzip wieder Selbstbeweihräucherung in dem Intro, das interessiert ja nicht wirklich.
Was sie beitragen können, sie kennen sich mit DevOps, Container-Technologie und vernetzten
IT-Systemen aus und Infrastructure as Code ist für sie kein Fremdwort. Klingt doch schon mal
ganz gut, würde relativ gut auf mich passen. Ich meine, ich suche keinen Job, aber ich kann es ja
nur aus meiner Erfahrung beurteilen. Denkst du, das Lenksystem läuft auf Kubernetes? Ja,
Raketen nur mit Cloud-Anbindung. Wenn die Verbindung unterbrochen wird, hat man halt
Pech. Dafür kannst du vom Smartphone steuern. So persönlicher Marschflugkörper vom Dach.
Steuern mit dem Handy wie eine Drohne dann. Aber ohne Cloud, ohne China-Chinesen-Cloud ist
dann die Microservice-Rakete. Hey, da haben wir wenigstens mal eine Anwendung für Written in Rust,
weil so ein Raketenbetriebssystem wäre vielleicht wirklich ganz gut, wenn es nicht crasht während
dem Flug. Ja, bei vielem ist es egal, ob es crasht, aber wenn so eine Rakete crasht und an
der falschen Stelle runterfällt, ist es vielleicht nicht so toll, nicht so gut. Das ist dann RAS,
Rocket as a Service. Also, das Erste klingt doch schon mal ganz gut. Sie haben langjährige
Erfahrung in der Administration von Linux-Betriebssystemen. Ja, habe ich auch. Sie möchten
bei der Einführung von Produkten und bei der Umsetzung einer Pri-. Naja, das fällt dabei ab.
Ja, Agile. Ja, für den wäre das was. Ich glaube übrigens, dass der gelöscht wurde von. Ne,
der ist noch da. By the way, das bin ich nicht. Das ist der Echte. Das ist der Echte. Der Einzige.
Und ich habe das Account-Passwort nicht mehr. Ich kann mich noch nicht einmal einloggen. Bei
uns gibt es auch eine DevOps-Stelle. Kann ich mir gleich angucken. Haben wir heute genug Zeit.
Okay, also, wenn wir das alles wollen, perfekt. Dann könnte diese Stelle ihr nächster Karriere-Schritt
als IT-Systemmanager sein. Können die sich mal entscheiden, was die eigentlich haben wollen?
Sie wollen einen IT-Administrator DevOps. Das ist eh. Okay, ja. Lass ich mir noch gefallen.
Haben wir halt einfach zwei Sachen zusammen geklatscht. Aber hier soll ich jetzt IT-Systemmanager
werden. Ja, was denn jetzt? Ja, zwei. Naja. Perfekt. Dann könnt ihr jetzt ja mit ihrer
Erfahrung, ihrem Know-How und ihrer Leidenschaft können sie sich bei den folgenden Themen und
Aufgaben bei uns einbringen. Also, jetzt kommt das eigentlich, was sie haben wollen. Aufbau,
Betrieb und Weiterentwicklung einer Container-Infrastruktur auf Basis moderner,
auf Basis modernen. Der Satz ist komisch. Auf Basis moderner Plattformen. Das hätte
man Chat-GPT noch mal Probe lesen lassen sollen. Plattformen wie Red Hat OpenShift. Jemand von
euch schon mal die Ehre gehabt mit OpenShift? Ich habe nur Schlechtes gehört. Kein Spaß. Ich
will es jetzt nicht bashen, aber ich habe wirklich nur Schlechtes gehört bisher. Ist solide. Okay,
solide heißt, es macht, was es soll, aber man hat eigentlich keinen Bock, sich großartig damit zu
beschäftigen. Das finde ich wiederum ganz cool. Das finde ich wiederum ganz cool, was ich bisher
gesehen habe von. Jemand von euch Erfahrungen damit? Also, das, was ich bisher davon gesehen
habe, fand ich ganz, ganz nice. Quasi Kubernetes API auf VMware. Oder vergleichbare Technologien.
Permanente Weiterentwicklung der API. Okay, bla bla bla bla bla bla. Beratung, Unterstützung.
Okay, Zusammenarbeit, Abstimmung. Ja, Übernahme der verantwortungstechnischen Aspekte. Okay,
was sie mitbringen sollten. Achso, ich dachte, das da. Fundierte Kenntnisse mit Containertechnologien
wie OpenShift, Docker oder Kubernetes. Erfahrung im Betrieb von Enterprise Linux Infrastruktur. Ja,
ja, habe ich Erfahrung mit. Expertise in der Automatisierung von IT-Prozessen. So viel
Erfahrung mit einer Scripting-Sprache wie Bash. Ja, YAML. Das passt in die Aufzählung nicht so
wirklich rein, aber es ist nicht verkehrt, dass YAML drinsteht, weil gerade solche Jobs hier,
die sind mittlerweile mehr YAML-Engineer als DevOps-Engineer. Hohe Belastbarkeit,
Eigenverantwortung. Ja, bla bla. Engagie. Okay, okay. Was wir ihnen bieten werden. Okay,
zeig mal her. Flexible Arbeitszeit, Kleidzeit, anteilige Mobilarbeit möglich. Okay, ja. Bis zu
80.000 Euro pro Job. Wo ist denn das? Schrobenhausen. Wo zum Geier ist Schrobenhausen? Maps.
Schrobenhausen. Ach, irgendwo in München. Okay, da brauche ich einfach nur fünf Stunden mit dem
Zug hin oder so. Ich sage eh nichts, aber trotzdem. Bis zu 80.000 Euro Brutto-Jahresgehalt im ersten
Beschäftigungsjahr. Ich denke mal, sie wollen damit quasi suggerieren, es geht noch mehr. Ja,
also ganz ehrlich, im Münchner Umfeld, ich kann es, ich werde das jetzt einfach mal ungefähr an
Frankfurter Finanzbranche festmachen, weil Frankfurt und München und so,
das kostet alles Geld. Ich denke, das ist okay als Einstiegsgehalt, aber in der heutigen Zeit
ist da, denke ich, gerade Richtung München auch noch Luft nach oben. Wenn es denn 80.000 Euro gibt,
bis zu 80.000 Euro kann auch sagen, ach ne, für sie geben wir bloß 60.000 Euro aus.
Bei nicht vollständiger Entfüllung der Stellenanforderung. Das ist doch jetzt schon
das erste Argument, um das Gehalt zu drücken. Du wirst immer einen Punkt finden, wo jemand nicht
so krass Pfeilfett ist, aber das sollte egal sein. Wenn die denken, dass er für den Job passt,
dann sollen sie ihm gefälligst ein ordentliches Gehalt geben. Automatisch steigen uns Brutto-Jahre
um bis zu 14% innerhalb der ersten beiden Beschäftigungsjahre. Okay, dann geht es,
also 80k plus dann der nächste Fit, dann geht es dann so langsam in die Richtung,
wo ich sagen würde, kann man dann schon das mal machen. Das ist dann schon ganz okay.
Habe am Donnerstag ein Vorstellungsgespräch als Java-Entwickler bei einer Bank, noch irgendwelche
Tipps? Ja, guck dir im Vorfeld mal an, was die so benutzen. Oder hast du da schon was rausgekriegt?
Erzähl mal, was benutzen die so? Bestimmt Springboot. Wenn Java, dann Springboot. Weil
jeder irgendwie aktuell Springboot verwendet. Leistungsorientiert? Ach, das ist mit nach
Tarifvertrag. Okay, nicht so spannend hier. Ja, ich denke, wenn man aus der Region kommt,
ist das sicherlich nicht schlecht. Klingt eigentlich ganz okay. Und ich würde sagen,
vom Profil her wäre das auch was, was mich durchaus ansprechen würde. Ja,
gerade die Kombination, dass das hauptsächlich... Von Cloud steht hier jetzt nichts. Es sieht also
auch eher aus, dass das Ganze offline betrieben wird. Also die Raketensteuerung geht über ein
On-Prem-Kubernetes-Cluster dann. Aber ich finde es nicht verkehrt. Wird mir zumindest von den
Aufgaben her gefallen. Warum sind sie doch in guter Gesellschaft? Die wissen wenigstens,
wie man Raketen steuert. Ich glaube eher, dass die den Kram selbst... Auch mit VMware-Tanzu und
sowas. Das sieht eher aus, als wollen die viel selbst betreiben. Finde ich nicht übel. Also
Mr. Brawl, ich weiß ja nicht. Entweder arbeitest du dort und wolltest wissen, was ich davon denke
oder willst dich da bewerben. In welchem Fall auch immer. Also falls du dich da bewerben willst,
ich denke, kannst du schon machen. Klingt nicht übel. Springboot, React, Postgres und Applikationen
sollen in der Azure Cloud laufen. Dann kann ich dir einen Tipp geben. Wie gut kennst du dich mit
Cloud aus? Guck dir mal ein paar Cloud-Buzzwords an. Ohne Scheiß, es ist immer nicht verkehrt,
wenn man ein bisschen was in der Hinterhand hat, wenn es auf das Thema geht. Zum Beispiel,
wenn du ganz cool sein willst, nennst du das nicht Cloud-Anbieter, sondern du kannst anmerken,
dass das ja mittlerweile eigentlich Hyperscaler sind. Und wenn dich dann einer fragt, was ein
Hyperscaler ist, dann sagst du, es sind Cloud-Anbieter. Also da würde ich tatsächlich,
wenn du weißt, dass die... Es ist immer Spaß beiseite. Wenn die... Ist kein Spaß, ist wirklich
so. Hyperscaler. Die skalieren auch noch diagonal. Das haben sich alles von uns abgeguckt. Aber jetzt
mal ernsthaft. Wenn die was von Azure Cloud schreiben, dann spricht nichts dagegen, so mal
grob so ein bisschen bei Microsoft rumzugucken. Dass du zum Beispiel weißt, gebe ich dir
einen Tipp jetzt, was sicherlich gut ankommt. Sag, dass Azure einen Kosten-Calculator hat,
also einen öffentlichen Kosten-Calculator. Also wenn du nämlich sowas sagst, da wissen die,
dass du dich schon mal mit Cloud-Kostenoptimierung... Naja, Kostenoptimierung ist das falsche Wort.
Also dass Cloud nicht so teuer auseinandergesetzt wird. Also das kannst du denen zum Beispiel sagen,
dass es dabei für Azure einen öffentlichen... Was es so kosten wird, also den hier meine ich,
Azure Calculator. Google hat übrigens sowas auch. AWS bin ich mir nicht sicher,
von AWS habe ich noch nicht gesehen. Guck, sowas haben die hier bei Azure. Da kannst du sagen,
ich hätte gerne ein Azure Kubernetes und dann machen wir was Einfaches. Ja, und dann braucht
das Ding ewig, weil das sackt. Ja, und dann siehst du, okay, kostet was, Region sowieso,
Nodes. Wir machen das mal kurz rückgängig. Wir machen das mal easy jetzt. Guck,
diese Seite ist so kacke, Alter. Nein! Die Seite macht mich immer fertig, ey. Sag mal,
du willst eine VM haben? Oh, View. Kannst du sagen hier, Region ist eigentlich egal,
Operating System, Linux, Debian, obbei das auch wurscht ist. Debian Tier, da kannst du dir
überlegen. Kategorie, blablabla, dann nimmst du irgendwie ein bisschen... Okay,
weiß ich aus dem Kopf nicht. Die Bezeichnungen bei Azure sind komplett pp-iger. Ich habe absolut
keine Ahnung, was da was ist, aber man sieht es ja hinten. Ein Core, 8 Core, 14g RAM, eine virtuelle
Maschine, kostet im Monat 350 Dollar. Also da kannst du, denke ich, einen ganz guten Eindruck
machen, wenn du weißt, dass es so einen Kosten-Calculator gibt für Azure, falls du ein
bisschen ausgefragt wirst. Ansonsten, ich gehe mal davon aus, wenn du dich bewirbst und die das
als Anforderung haben, wirst du dich damit schon ganz gut auskennen, weil sonst wirst du dich da
wahrscheinlich nicht bewerben bzw. hättest dich mit denen nicht geeinigt soweit. Aber gerade bei
Azure kann man ein bisschen punkten. Also das mit dem Kosten-Calculator kommt, denke ich,
immer gut an, wenn man sowas weiß. Ansonsten, wenn du ein bisschen in Azure rumgeklickert hast,
ist sicherlich auch nicht verkehrt. Bei Azure kannst du ja auch sagen, falls sich das einer
fragt, zum Einstieg ist Azure super, weil es gibt, glaube ich, 300 Dollar oder so Probe-Account. Und
du kannst ihnen sagen, Cloud kann günstig sein, ist aber meistens nicht günstiger. Dafür hat es
andere Vorteile und dann wäre es gut, wenn du ihnen ein paar Vorteile sagen könntest. Also das musst
du wissen. Das mit dem Calculator würde ich denen auf jeden Fall erzählen, dass du das weißt. Auf
den ganzen Job-Seiten steht... Moment, ich muss mal gucken. Ich hatte doch früher was eingestellt,
dass es gehighlighted wurde. Chat, habe ich irgendwas von Highlights gesehen? Filtering,
Highlight. Genau, weil da konnte man doch eigentlich einstellen, dass wenn, wenn Wobblers
geschrieben wird. Ich bin zu dumm. Bin zu dumm. Highlight-Matched-Words. Ah, das habe ich gesucht,
dass es hervorgehoben wird. Also auf den ganzen Job-Seiten stehen immer 50, 60 K für Software-Empfindung.
Ich glaube deine Einschätzung schon, aber kann es sein, dass du auch einfach über... Nee. Also ja,
in Frankfurt Finanzbranche nicht, weil ich FISI mal gelernt habe. Aber ehrlich gesagt,
in 50 und 60 K, man kann das ganz einfach daran festmachen. Guck mal. Mal unabhängig davon,
dass es jetzt sicherlich kein schlecht bezahlter Job ist, den ich jetzt habe. Aber man kann das
ganz einfach festmachen. Ich habe nach meiner Ausbildung als Einstiegsgehalt 33.500 Euro
verdient. Und das ist 15 Jahre her. So. Wir haben das letztens mal hochgerechnet. Ich glaube,
das wären heute, glaube ich, 48 K oder sowas. Wir haben das letztens mal ausgerechnet. Das wären,
glaube ich, 48 K heute. So. Und das ist wirklich komplett nach der Ausbildung direkt eingestiegen.
Das heißt, jeder mit ein bisschen... Das war auch in Frankfurt, ja. Und jeder mit ein bisschen
Erfahrung sollte da auf jeden Fall drüber sein. Wie das jetzt im Osten aussieht oder irgendwie
im Osten auf dem Land oder so, das kann ich nicht sagen. Keine Ahnung. Ich meine,
es ist jetzt nicht so, als bin ich hier wandelndes Deutschland-Gehaltslexikon.
Kann ich das nur bei mir erzählen. Größter Gehaltswechsel ist immer noch der Jobwechsel.
Das stimmt wohl, ja. Das stimmt wohl. Aber ich gebe euch jetzt mal wirklich den besten Tipp ever.
Ihr müsst Ahnung haben. Ich will mich nicht super loben und sagen, ich bin der krasseste Checker
überhaupt. Das stimmt nicht. Ich habe von ganz vielen Sachen weiß ich, dass ich keine Ahnung
habe. Zum Beispiel, warum wir hier gerade was von Datenbanken hatten. Also Datenbanken ist auf
jeden Fall ein Punkt. Da kriege ich so Basics hin. Aber großartige Ahnung von Datenbanken oder wie
man da irgendwelche Query-Magic macht, habe ich null. Kenne ich mich nicht mit aus. Ich würde
mich tatsächlich mal ganz gerne beschäftigen mit Postgres-Skalierung. Also mit mehreren Read-Instanzen
und einer Write-Instanz. Habe ich aber noch nie gemacht. Habe ich keine Ahnung. Es gibt genug
Punkte, wo ich mich nicht mit auskenne. Aber man muss sich tatsächlich einfach auskennen. Und am
besten natürlich in der Kombination, was dann auch gesucht wird. Also beziehungsweise das,
was in der jeweiligen Stellenanzeige gesucht wird. Wenn man einfach nur ein bisschen Windows
Assistenten durch... Ich meine übrigens nicht damit dich explizit. Würde ich jetzt bloß mal
sagen. Ich will dich nicht flamen oder so, sondern nur allgemein erzählt. Wenn man jetzt nur ein
bisschen in Windows Assistenten weiter, weiter Finish klicken kann, dann muss man sich nicht
wundern, dass keiner bereit ist, dafür viel Kohle zu bezahlen. Wenn man aber irgendwas hinbekommt
und das gut und das, wo es nicht so viele gibt und wenn man da vor allem auch ein bisschen
Erfahrung vorzuweisen hat. So nach dem Motto, man labert nicht einfach nur, sondern man benutzt das
auch schon eine Weile. Man hat vielleicht auch die ein oder anderen Projekte vorzuweisen. Man
hat Erfahrung vorzuweisen, was man in dem Bereich gemacht hat. Und wenn das dann was ist, was die
suchen, dann sind die auch bereit, Kohle dazulassen. Für eine 0815 Windows Assistenten-Klicker
vielleicht weniger. Aber es gibt genug Sachen, wo ich auch keinen Plan von habe. Aber so in
manchen Sachen ist nicht verkehrt, wo man sich auskennt. Und jetzt ultimativer Tipp. Am besten
ist das, ihr kennt euch in was aus. Ja, okay, was gesucht wird, aber das schwankt. Deswegen ist es
besser. Ihr kennt euch in was aus, was euch Bock macht, weil das ist eigentlich so ein
selbsterhaltender Kreislaufsystem. Wenn ihr euch in was auskennt, in was euch Bock macht, dann
lernt ihr das einfacher, lernt das schneller. Es macht Spaß beim Lernen. Euch stört es auch gar
nicht so sehr, wenn ihr euch da am Wochenende mal ein bisschen was anguckt. Und umso besser ihr in
dem Bereich werdet, umso einfacher ist es, was in dem Bereich zu finden, wo auch Leute mit Expertise,
also mit tiefgreifender Expertise gesucht werden. Und dann kann man da tatsächlich sogar noch ein
bisschen mehr verdienen, weil man ja schon richtig viel Plan davon hat. Und dadurch kann man dann auch
das machen, worauf man Bock hat. Auf der Arbeit wird noch besser und es macht Spaß, weil das ein
Gebiet ist, worauf man Bock hat. Sich in einem Gebiet zu spezialisieren, nur weil man denkt, es
könnte Geld bringen, halte ich für den falschen Ansatz. Also zum Beispiel Leute, die sagen, ey Max,
ich habe gehört, als Kobold-Programmierer kann man super viel Geld verdienen. Es mag zwar den
einen oder anderen geben, der richtig Bock auf Kobold hat, aber ich behaupte immer, die meisten
sind es nicht. Und jetzt einfach Kobold zu lernen, nur weil man gehört hat, dass Kobold-Entwickler
viel Geld verdienen, finde ich ist eine bescheuerte Idee. Man sollte sich was raussuchen, was einem
selbst Spaß macht, was einem selbst gefällt, wo ein das Lernen auch nicht nervt, weil ansonsten ist
es so, in einem halben Jahr braucht das keiner mehr, gibt die fünf weitere Versionen davon und du
hast keinen Bock mehr, dich mit auseinanderzusetzen. Also deswegen, es ist immer wichtig, dass man was
kann. Man muss nicht alles können. Ich kann auch extrem viel gar nicht. Ich kann sicherlich viel,
viel mehr gar nicht, als das, was ich kann. Aber gerade im Linux-Bereich kenne ich mich doch ganz
gut aus. Also im Linux-Cloud-Bereich und so ein bisschen drumherum. Da kenne ich mich mittlerweile
doch ganz gut aus. Und mit Shit kenne ich mich auch aus. Ich bin sogar schon auf der neuen Arbeit
wieder, der Shit-Expert. Ich werde immer angerufen jetzt, wenn irgendwas mit unseren Git-Repos ist.
So schnell kann das gehen. Ich habe da angefangen, habe einmal, eins, zweimal erzählt, ey, wenn ihr
Fragen habt, so mit Git und so, ich habe gesehen, manche tun sich da ein bisschen schwer, sagt
einfach Bescheid, ruft an, wir können uns das zusammen angucken. Habe ich mit zwei, drei Leuten
gemacht, jetzt rufen die mich immer an, sobald irgendwas mit Git ist. So nach dem Motto, oh, ich
habe irgendwelche Dinger committed, irgendwo dahin gepusht, wo ich nicht wollte. Kannst mal gucken.
Easy, wird geguckt, Viertelstunde später geht das alles wieder. Aber, aber Chat, ich bin auch,
ich bin auch oldschool. Ich benutze auch Git-Checkout und nicht Git-Switch. Was kann bei Git-Kurs schief
gehen? Oh doch, da kann jede Menge schief gehen. Wenn Leute nicht genau wissen, was sie da machen,
da gibt es zum Beispiel welche, die versuchen, in Protected Master zu pushen, Leute, die 50
Commits erstellt haben, Leute, die eventuell auch falsche Sachen rebased haben, da kann ganz schön
viel schief gehen. Ich verstehe es teilweise auch nicht, wie man das auf die Reihe kriegt, aber da
kann ganz schön viel schief gehen. Und ich mache das auch gern, weil das ein Thema ist, was, was,
was mir gefällt, ja. Das stimmt, ich gucke, ich gucke mir sehr viel, ich habe halt den riesen Vorteil,
ich mache ja auch noch Stream so und so und wir können uns so Sachen zusammen im Stream angucken,
aber oftmals, habt ihr es ja sicherlich auch schon gemerkt, Sachen, die wir hier im Stream machen,
also ich mache selten Sachen im Stream, wo ich gar keine Ahnung im Vorfeld habe. Ich habe es
meistens auf Stream schon mal ein bisschen vorher angeguckt. Außer, ja, so Kleinigkeiten,
so Kotlin oder so, das habe ich mir vorher wirklich noch nicht angeguckt. Ich habe keine
Ahnung davon gehabt. Höre ich jetzt implizit auch so mit dem Drücken von Kosten in der Cloud also
nicht unbedingt, nicht unbedingt, aber es macht auf jeden Fall einen guten Eindruck,
wenn du Cloud-Infrastruktur, sagen wir mal, etwas kostenoptimiert aufbaust und verwaltest. Also,
dass du keine dauerhafte Kiste mit 64 Gigabyte RAM laufen hast, nur weil es die einmalig braucht.
Ja, wenn du, guck mal, es ist ja easy, wenn man einen Service hat, der 64 Gigabyte RAM braucht,
dass man dann sagt, oh je, das muss 64 Gigabyte RAM bekommen, aber okay, vielleicht braucht es
das Service nur einmal initial. Und da muss man halt sich überlegen, ob man die Cloud oder
Cloud-Technologie nicht gerade mit dem nutzt, was Cloud-Technologie ausmacht, dass man sie nämlich
gut skalieren kann. Dass man halt nicht dauerhaft immer 100 Prozent der theoretisch irgendwann mal
nötigen Ressourcen sich auch bezahlt, sondern dass man das nach Möglichkeit halt auch wieder ein
bisschen runterskaliert. Also, das macht schon ganz guten Eindruck, wenn du nicht einfach nur
sinnlos Geld verbringst. Ich kann euch übrigens mal so eine kleine Zahl verraten. Wir haben auf
der Arbeit in unserem Projekt 35.000 Euro verbraucht diesen Monat in der Google Cloud. Und nicht
insgesamt, sondern haltet euch mal fest, ratet mal für was. Ratet mal für was. Nicht etwa für
4Ms oder Kubernetes-Nodes oder Functions oder so. Ich kann es euch sagen. CI? Ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne.
APK-Calls, Logging? Ah, es geht ungefähr in die richtige Richtung, aber ist es auch nicht. Nein,
Netzwerk-Traffic. Das müsst ihr erst mal schaffen, 35.000 Euro Netzwerk-Traffic zu generieren. Ja,
das ist nicht ohne. Ich überlege gerade, ob ich euch erzählen soll, woran es... Ja, kann
ich machen, ist nichts Geheimes. Wie das geht? Okay, ich erzähle es euch. Wenn du private
Blockchain-Nodes synchronisierst, also nicht private Blockchain, wenn du Blockchain-Nodes
synchronisierst. Full Blockchain-Node. Frag mich nicht, wie das Zeug genau heißt. Ja, also mal
angenommen, du machst einen eigenen Ethereum-Node oder sowas und den machst du mit kompletter
History, synchst du den. Das macht ordentlich Netzwerk-Traffic. Und wenn du das ein paar mal
machst mit ein paar Nodes, dann, ja, dann verursacht das ordentlich Traffic. Als Feezy
verdienst du nicht über... Ach, du meinst, dass ich überdurchschnittlich für den Feezy verdiene?
Naja. Ja, ist so. Ich verdiene aber wahrscheinlich überdurchschnittlich für die meisten Berufe. Das
heißt, es ist kein... Jetzt nicht unbedingt der Maßstab, den man da anlegen sollte. Machen wir
mal weiter. Kein Bock jetzt irgendwie in Selbstlobpreisung oder so zu verfallen. Kannst du
mit dem Turbine-Programm der NSA unter... Was? Ne, keine Ahnung, was das sein soll. Wie viel
Terabyte waren das? Weiß ich nicht. Muss ich mal in die Statistik gucken. Auf WeirdFlex. Tja. War
nicht als Flex gedacht, aber wenn es so rüberkommt, was soll ich machen? 50k für fünf Jahre Entwickler
erscheint mir dann doch ein bisschen sehr wenig. Hi, es ist Joey. Dankeschön für den Sub. Ach,
sorry, Leute. Ich habe bestimmt heute wieder die Hälfte vergessen an Subs. Sekunde, ich gucke mal.
Ich glaube, so viele waren es gar nicht. Stream Manager. Ne, haben nichts übersehen. Gut. Wie
fängt man am besten an, wenn man den Bereich IT-Security sich fortbilden möchte? Was ist
da dann First Step? Was ist da First Step? Ich hätte jetzt eigentlich gesagt, das ergibt sich
von alleine, aber... Was ist da First Step? Das wollte ich auch sagen, aber ich würde nicht sagen,
dass das ein sinnvoller First Step ist, wenn du noch... Sich mit Lehnungsbeschäftigungen zum
Beispiel, wenn du noch gar keine Ahnung hast. Das wäre ein sinnvoller First Step. Und mit den
üblichen Tools, sowas wie Wireshark zum Beispiel oder irgendwelche Load-Generierungstools. Natürlich,
natürlich erstmal Kali-Linux starten, natürlich. Aber wozu? Wenn man auch Arch verwenden kann.
Beste. Das hat schon seinen Sinn. Ich bin jetzt 41 und vor drei Wochen sind wir fast gleich alt,
auch wenn mir das wieder keiner glaubt, aber mir kommt es selbst schwierig vor,
dass mich nicht viel zu 41 trennt. Mich trennen noch zwei Jahre zu 41. Und vor drei Wochen mit
meiner Umschul-Physi fertiggekommen. Fange morgen bei einer Münchner Firma mit 2 an. Das ist aber
echt für Münchner Verhältnisse wirklich... Ja, okay. Also als Einstiegsgehalt würde ich sagen,
mag das okay gehen, aber München ist halt auch übelst teuer. Übrigens ist exakt das Einstiegsgehalt,
was ich auch hatte. Wir haben es ja hochgerechnet. Ich habe 33.500 Euro bekommen als Einstiegsgehalt.
Das ist hochgerechnet jetzt ungefähr 48k. Ja, aber also für Münchner Verhältnisse hoffe ich,
dass sie dann die nächsten Jahre über noch ein bisschen zulegen. Altersgrenze bei Twitch
für Streamer. Ich glaube unter 12 darfst du nicht streamen. Das stimmt wohl, aber es gibt sicherlich
noch welche. Es gibt sicherlich noch genug Leute, die Ansible, Playbooks und Terraform falsch schreiben
können. Aber sicherlich weniger als Windows Assistenten durchklicken. Mir fällt jetzt kein
Beispiel ein, aber es gibt schon so ein paar Nischendinger, die man sich ganz gut bezahlen
lassen kann. Und Ansible und Terraform sind definitiv keine Nischendinger. Ja, die werden
wahrscheinlich nicht glücklich werden. Bildhub Actions Pro. Haben wir doch im Stream schon gesehen.
Übrigens, bei der Gelegenheit gibt es ein Git. Wie war das? Gitclean oder Gitperch? Ich kann es
mir immer nicht merken. Ich glaube Gitclean ist es, dass er auch Dateien löscht, die nicht mehr
in der History oder nie in der History drin waren. Die beste Variante ist eigentlich immer
rm-rf.git und wieder von vorne anfangen. Easy. Dann hat man immer ein sauberes Repo. Das mache
ich nicht, aber ich bin Gitcheckout-Enjoyer. Gitcheckout, Gitcheckout-B und ich verwende
auch nicht... Wie heißt das andere neue? Es gab ja zwei neue Sachen. Gitcheckout und...
Gitswitch, Gitswitch und... Es gab noch was Neues. Gitrestore, genau. Ja, verwende ich alles nicht.
Checkout-Enjoyer. Hast du das jetzt gerade geschrieben, zufällig, als ich das gesagt
habe oder sind wir beide auf die gleiche blöde Idee gekommen? Oh, das wird spannend. Also 60k
als Einstieg dürften durchaus okay sein, auch mit Studium. Wenn man jetzt allerdings schon Jahre
Erfahrung hat und je nachdem, wo man wohnt, ist das dann doch vielleicht ein bisschen wenig.
Ihr müsst euch immer mal eine Sache vor Augen führen, wenn es um aktuelle Gehaltsforderungen
geht. Ihr habt den großen Luxus aktuell, dass ihr, wo ihr hinguckt, gesucht werdet. An jeder
Ecke, irgendwo. Techniker, IT-Leute, IT-Techniker, Admins, Softwareentwickler, DevOps-Leute,
Netzwerktechniker, das werden alle überall, an jeder Ecke gesucht. Das heißt, wenn es bei euch
irgendwo nicht weitergeht, die beste Sache ist, sich einfach mal umschauen, was es drumherum so
gibt. Und es gibt garantiert drumherum was. Das heißt nicht, dass man zwangsläufig wechseln muss,
aber mal feststellen, wie viel man denn bekommen würde, ist, denke ich, auch ein bisschen ein
Boost in das Vertrauen in die eigenen Skills. Also man muss sich heute wirklich nicht mehr
unter Wert verkaufen. Es werden händeringend IT-Leute an allen Ecken und Enden gesucht.
Ne, das war unser Azubi. Ich würde mit Studium auch nicht mehr verdienen. Also mit 20 Jahren
sollte es mehr als 60k sein. Das stimmt für meine Ausbildung. Die Ausbildung juckt keinen. Ja,
leider. Mr. Robot. Ohne Mist, ich fand Mr. Robot die erste Staffel mega nice. Leider war das Ende
relativ schwach und ab der Mitte der ersten Staffel ging es eigentlich schon los, dass es
um die psychischen Probleme von Elliot ging. Und ich habe Mr. Robot nie Staffel 2, 3, 4, 5,
weiß nicht wie viele es da gibt, noch geguckt. Kennst du eigentlich Reddit Arbeitsleben? Ja,
da lese ich jeden Tag drinnen. Auf dem Handy. Reddit Arbeitsleben, da sind immer die Leute,
die schreiben direkt Kündigung und zum Anwalt. Und solche Dinger. Direkt Kündigung und zum Anwalt.
Sowas. Also ob man sich da so viele Ratschläge holen sollte, naja. Ich glaube nichts. Auf was
basiert Kali-Linux-based-on-Debian, genau. Abt. Ich weiß nicht, wie ich Merge-Konflikte
in Git löse. Man muss es bald machen. Dann solltest du mich konsulten dazu, wenn es nicht
funktioniert. Also es ist tatsächlich gar nicht so kompliziert. Aber ein grafisches Merge-UI ist
gestattet. Das erlaube ich dem HiIQ-Chat. Also grafisches Merge-GUI ist okay, alles andere
reines CLI, please. Keine Ahnung. Mit Vervorstellung gehört Captain Poggers, der macht das schon.
Sag einfach Wobblers Prime Subscription. Mod bei Wobblers, da kann nichts schiefgehen. Ist das
die Stelle, die du letztens gepostet hast? Richtig gut, sind wir fast schon durch. Nein. GUI. GUI
für Git sagt. Ja, hab ich. Ah, siehste? Chat-GUI, haben wir es auch geschafft. Dann gucken wir uns
doch jetzt mal an, was hier bei der Stellenanzeige rumkommt. Ich hab schon wieder vergessen, wer
sie gepostet hat. Hab ich irgendwelche anderen Sachen im Chat übersprungen? Falls ja, müsst ihr
leider noch mal schreiben. Ich hab jetzt recht schnell durchgescrollt. Also was haben wir hier
noch? Infrastruktur. Oh, Infrastrukturmanager. Moment. Infrastrukturmanager und Infrastrukturspezialist.
Ja, Manager juckt mich nicht. Dann lieber Spezialist. Bei? Wo? In Jena. Ja. Ach, wo,
weiß man. Ach hier, Zeiss. Männlich-Weiblich-Twitter, genau. Verantwortung für die Anforderungsanalyse
und Umsetzung sowie Konzeption und Administration unserer Kubernetes-Klasse. Aha. Kubernetes am Start.
Infrastrukturprojekte, Storage-Lösungen, DevSec. Warte, das ist doch zu wenig. DevSec bis WinSecOps,
wenn schon. Verwaltung und Konfiguration, Zertifikate und Secret-Manager, Flux. Oh. Wobei
das ja eigentlich ehrlich gesagt nichts mit Zertifikaten zu tun hat, aber halt die Kubernetes-Deployment.
Wie spricht man das eigentlich aus? ACME, ACME, das ist dieses Let's-Sign-Crypt-Protokoll.
Azure Key Vault. Okay, das macht Sinn. Ja, okay. Alles gut. Würde ich mich wieder auskennen. Auch
wenn ich nichts suche, aber ich tue ja immer so, als ob. Ja. ACME, ACME, ACME, ACAMI. Aufsetzen,
betreuen und weiterentwickeln eine Machine Learning und AI-Umgebung. Ja, was macht die
denn bei ZEISS? Ich dachte, die stellen da irgendwelche Linsen her. Nice. Tja, da wird
richtig high IQ-Zeug gemacht. Umfangreiches Verständnis von IT-Systemen. Ja, das würde ich
sagen, das fände ich verkehrt dafür. Bereitschaft bzw. Interesse, Wissen in aktuellen IT-Querschnittsthemen
zu erwerben und auszubauen. Was genau verstehen die in dem Fall unter IT-Querschnittsthemen?
Das ist so Business-Speak. Da kann ich nichts mit anfangen. Die YouTube-Tabs. Wieso? Wir haben
noch ein bisschen mehr hier. Guck, da haben wir auch noch welche. Erfahrung in Docker, Swarm,
MonkaS. Wollten die nicht oben noch Kubernetes? Doch. Kubernetes. Docker, ach hier. Docker,
Swarm, Kubernetes, Python. HPC-Erfahrung ist ein Plus. Ist HPC High-Performance-Computing
oder sowas? Ich rate das jetzt einfach. Ich weiß nicht, was HP oder High-Availability
irgendwas. Kenntnisse der gängigen Cloud-Plattformen. GCP, AWS, Azure habe ich auch. Außer AWS. AWS
ist nicht so wirklich da, da ich da viel planen von hätte. Umfangreiche Linux-Kenntnisse bzw.
Patchen und Kompilieren von Linux. Kernel-Hackermans, Leute. Die wollen es aber echt wissen. Ja,
kriege ich aber auch gebacken. Solange ich nicht neue Kernel-Funktionalität in C
programmieren soll, wenn es fertige Patches gibt, ist das kein Problem. Ein paar Zeilen würde ich
mir da auch zutrauen, aber nicht, dass das am Ende auch gescheit funktioniert. Erstmal Gentoo
an Start bringen. Hohe Eigenständigkeit, Durchsetzungs- und Kommunikationsstärke
runden ihr Profil ab. Also meine Erfahrung mit Leuten ist eher, dass es selten in Kombination
ist. Also Leute, die besonders durchsetzungsstark sind, das sind nicht unbedingt die Leute,
die sonderlich kommunikationsstark sind, insofern, dass man mit denen gerne zusammenarbeiten möchte.
Die gehen ja eher auf den Sack, die ihr Ding durchdrücken wollen. Aber ich gette das,
das ist so ein Standard-015-Satz. Ausschreibung für die ganze IT-Abteilung? Nö, ich finde nicht.
Ich finde, das passt in dem Fall ganz gut. Die suchen jemanden, der sich mit Linux und Cloud
auskennt. Fertig. Den Rest, brauchst nicht viel Ahnung von Machine Learning, gehe ich mal von aus,
wenn du da anfängst. Das schwebt denen wahrscheinlich nicht vor, dass du Ahnung
von Machine Learning hast, den sie da einstellen. Ich finde, das passt eigentlich ganz gut. Die
suchen jemanden, der sich ein bisschen mit Cloud und Komponiert ist und Linux auskennt. Das ist
ja eine Kombination, die jetzt vielleicht nicht an jeder Ecke, aber die gibt es ja durchaus schon
öfters mal. Mit bis zu 60% mobilem Arbeiten. Heißt das auch 60% Homeoffice nur? 60% Homeoffice wäre
mir persönlich ein bisschen wenig. Ein Tag die Woche ist gut. Mehr als ein Tag die Woche in die
Stadt hätte ich echt keinen Bock drauf. Eine angenehme Arbeitsatmosphäre, eine intensive
Einarbeitung und Mentorenprogramm. Ich finde das immer geil, wenn die reinschreiben, wir bieten und
dann steht eine Einarbeitung. Ich denke mir halt so, eine ordentliche Einarbeitung für neue
Mitarbeiter sollte doch eigentlich so das ureigenste Interesse der Firma sein. Das ist doch jetzt kein
krasser Benefit. So nach dem Motto, wenn du bei uns anfängst, dann erklären wir dir auch alles,
was du brauchst, damit du ordentlich für uns arbeiten kannst. Das ist doch kein krasser Benefit,
oder? Ich verstehe es aber, das sind so eine Floskel, das schreiben viele. Langfristige
Perspektive steht okay. Ja, warum nicht? Kurz und knackig. Ich finde es eigentlich eine ganz
stimmige Stellenanzeige. Was ich auch schön finde ist, dass... Ah, hierneben ist es. Ich wollte gerade sagen,
dass hier drauf verzichtet wird, erstmal vorne drei Seiten über die eigene Firma zu schwadronieren,
wie geil die ist. Hierneben ist das genau richtig, weil das hier ist ja eigentlich, was die Leute
interessiert. Dann sind sie aber dumm, wenn sie das machen. Da bekommen sie ja nichts für ihr Geld.
Ich habe morgen Gehaltsverhandlungen, irgendwelche Tipps. Was hast du denn bis jetzt schon gemacht?
Also nicht, was du arbeitstechnisch gemacht hast, was du dir schon überlegt hast dafür? Also ein
diplomatischer Trick, den ich mal irgendwo gelesen habe, den ich selbst nicht angewendet
habe bisher, der aber, finde ich, ganz clever klang, ist, man soll nicht von Gehaltserhöhung,
sondern von Gehaltsanpassung sprechen, weil sich das besser anhört und also diplomatischer anhört.
Ansonsten, es ist immer von Vorteil, das habe ich glaube ich in einem der letzten Videos auch schon
erzählt. Du kannst übrigens mal was angucken von mir auf YouTube. Ich habe ein Video letztens dazu
gemacht, wie man eine Gehaltserhöhung bekommt. Da geht es eigentlich nur um 1-2 Themen, aber die,
finde ich, nicht verkehrt sind. Und im Prinzip geht es darum, dass es nicht nur reicht, tolle
Sachen zu machen, sondern dass es mindestens genauso wichtig ist, wenn man tolle Sachen
gemacht hat, ein bisschen drüber zu reden, dass man tolle Sachen gemacht hat. Weil wenn du einfach
nur den ganzen Tag da sitzt, vor dich hinarbeitest und quasi alle Tickets in Rekordzeit mit Top-
Ergebnissen abarbeitest, dann, wenn du Pech hast, also kommt immer ein bisschen drauf an, ob du einen
richtig, richtig guten Chef hast, der sich da reinhängt oder nicht, aber so ein bisschen weniger
Tickets, aber dafür ein bisschen mehr labern über die geilen Sachen, die man umgesetzt hat, ist
langfristig besser. Kann man bei Max nicht donaten? Nö, du kannst Prime subben. Also ich hatte mal einen
Donation-Link, aber ich fand es irgendwie... Spendet euer Geld lieber ans Tierheim als an mich. Prime
subbe reicht voll und ganz und ich freue mich auch, dass ihr einfach so da seid. Tja, und ansonsten,
falls du noch keine Liste hast, was du für tolle Sachen gemacht hast, dann schreib dir mal welche
auf für morgen und überleg dir schon mal, mit was du zufrieden bist und dann hau noch mal eine ganze
Ecke drauf. Darf ich mal fragen, KlitschDark, was schwebt dir denn vor? Ist das eine Gehaltsverhandlung,
die du anberaumt hast, weil du gesagt hast, Chef, wir müssen uns mal wieder unterhalten darüber oder
ist das irgendwas regelmäßiges, was eigentlich immer so ab und zu halt mal kommt und man macht
sich nicht so viele Gedanken drüber? Also, weil, was mich interessiert ist, was du... Du hast den
Termin angesetzt, das ist schon mal nicht verkehrt, da weißt du auf jeden Fall, dass du sehr ernst
bist. Ich habe mal einen Vortrag gesehen auf YouTube, da war eine gute Aussage dabei. Habe
ich ja auch in ein paar von meinen Videos schon erzählt, aber der hat das besser ausgedrückt,
als ich in den Videos und zwar, der hat gesagt, gerade wenn es um so Sachen wie Gehaltsverhandlungen
geht, ist es immer gut, man sagt selbst, was man, was man sich vorstellt, weil dann steht
erst mal eine Zahl im Raum und oder ein Prozentsatz im Raum und man muss immer deutlich mehr sagen,
als womit man zufrieden ist und der, wie hat er das genannt, der passende, ja, die passende
Messlatte ist. Ja, genau, genau, der Typ, genau. Habe ich vor ein paar Jahren mal geguckt, aber das
waren so zwei Sprüche, die habe ich mir, die habe ich mir gemerkt, genau. Er hat gesagt, man muss
das, das muss, Angebot muss kurz vordreist sein. Ich habe ja so Dinge auch schon in meinen Videos
erzählt, aber der hat es deutlich besser ausgedrückt. Gibt es grob eine Formel, wie viel Gehalt man pro
Jahr mal ansetzen kann? Also in aktuellen Zeiten von Inflation geht durch die Decke, bist du
wahrscheinlich gar nicht so schlecht dran, wenn man sich da irgendwie ein bisschen daran orientiert,
weil das wahrscheinlich schon mehr ist, als den meisten Chefs vorschwebt zu bezahlen. Sind 15
Prozent mehr dreist? Sag mal, es kommt ein bisschen darauf an, wann du die letzte Gehaltserhöhung
gekriegt hast, aber ansonsten würde ich sagen, nö. Wenn du das, wenn du das, wenn du das gut
begründen kannst, beziehungsweise wenn du irgendwie, ja, wie soll ich das ausdrücken? Wenn auch nie
einer deinen Namen gehört hat, ist es immer blöd zu sagen, ey Leute, ich mache ganz geiles Zeug und
ich will dafür mehr Geld haben. Das mag zwar alles stimmen, aber es fällt immer unglaublich schwer,
wenn die halt gar nicht das mitbekommen haben. Deswegen sage ich ja auch immer im Video, dass
es sinnvoll ist, vielleicht ein bisschen weniger wirklich zu machen und ein bisschen mehr über das
Geile, was man gemacht hat, zu erzählen. Gehaltsvorstellung beim Bewerben? Natürlich
musst du da einen Betrag sagen und das ist eigentlich ganz gut, wenn du schon ein bisschen
vorgefühlt hast, was da so geht. Wenn du gar keine Ahnung hast, was du sagen sollst,
dann kannst du dann, keine Ahnung, dann ist vielleicht nicht schlecht sich das anzuhören,
was sie zu sagen haben, aber ansonsten ist nicht verkehrt. Also ich kann, ich kann euch sagen,
wie das bei mir im Vorstellungsgespräch war. Ich weiß nicht mal, welchen Betrag ich genau gesagt
habe. Ich bin mir nicht mehr ganz sicher. Irgendwann ging es darum, wie viel Kohle man
verdienen sollte, also nicht, wie viel man verdienen sollte, wie viel Kohle ich verdiene,
wie viel Kohle ich verdienen will. Also sprich, und was haben sie so für Gehaltsvorstellung? Ich
weiß nicht mehr, wie der genaue Wort laut war. Das kriege ich jetzt aus dem Kopf nicht mehr hin
und ich habe mir das im Vorfeld natürlich alle schon überlegt und da habe ich denen gesagt 110.000
Euro. Da haben sie erst mal gemacht, ah, vielleicht ein bisschen viel und dann haben
sie mir das aber vorgerechnet, dass es mit Bonus doch ungefähr in diese Richtung geht. Und dann
habe ich gesagt, okay, passt. Ich glaube, die Spenden gehen, aber Chainlore, das habe ich
seit Jahren nicht mehr benutzt. Ich würde da kein Geld hin überweisen. Und da haben die gesagt,
ja, dann ist auch okay, wenn sie damit zufrieden sind. Dann waren wir beide zufrieden und gut ist.
Wahrscheinlich hätte ich sogar noch ein bisschen mehr sagen müssen. Aber sie haben schon die
übliche Ausrede gezogen, so nach dem Motto, ja, wir müssen ja auch gucken, dass das ins
Gehaltsgefüge passt und da wären 110.000 vielleicht ein bisschen viel. Und dann haben
sie mir aber vorgerechnet, dass es doch ungefähr das ist. Also wahrscheinlich habe ich relativ gut
das getroffen, was ihnen auch so als oberer Wert vorgeschwebt ist. Weißt du so aus dem Stand,
welchen Stundenlohn du hast? Nein, keine Ahnung. Ich meine, wir können das ausrechnen,
wenn euch das interessiert. Wartet mal, können das machen. Ich habe doch hier irgendwo die
Abrechnungs App von der Firma. Also wohlgemerkt, ich arbeite nur. Also das ist auch fünf. Das ist
auch fünf Tage hochgerechnet gewesen. Ja, ich arbeite nur vier Tage die Woche. So Vergütung
Brutto. Okay, also für vier Tage, vier Tage Woche bekomme ich Brutto 5.745,74 Euro. So,
Chat, geh, ihr müsst mir mal helfen. Quick maths. Das ist im Monat. Also können wir quasi sagen,
ich verdiene am, kann man das so rechnen? Kann man das so rechnen? Ich verdiene, also sind quasi
190 Euro am Tag. Kann man das so rechnen? Nee, man muss Arbeitstage rechnen, oder? Sonst macht
es ja keinen Sinn. Wie viele Arbeitstage habe ich denn so im Monat? Ich habe, lasst mal hier
gucken. Nehmen wir mal den Monat hier. Also was haben wir denn hier? Das da 4, 8, 12, 16. Also
ziemlich genau 16 Arbeitstage. Durch 16. Und dann haben wir das hier. Und das rechnen wir durch 7,
Alter, wie viele habe ich am Tag? 7,35 oder irgendwie sowas. Ja, 50 Euro ungefähr. Also
ungefähr 50 Euro. Aber das Brutto am Anfang war ohne Bonus. Ja, leider. Den Bonus gibt es nur
zwei, ich glaube zweimal im Jahr. Ich glaube den gibt es im, wobei das nicht so ganz stimmt. Das
stimmt nicht so ganz. Also unser Bonus wird, okay, ich muss ja, ich muss mal kurz den Chat
aufarbeiten. Da ist ja irgendwie noch, noch, ja, das würde ich auch sagen. Chat, Chat, ich komm,
ich komm gleich, ich komm gleich dazu. Unbedingt, unbedingt, Erfolg, das würde ich unbedingt
aufschreiben, ja. Das, das ist, das ist gut, ja. Am besten, am besten, ganz ehrlich, am besten die
Dinger erzählen, wo du dir, sag mal, wo die Wahrscheinlichkeit am höchsten ist, dass sie
deinen Chef und die da oben drüber auch mitbekommen haben. Das ist immer ganz gut, weil dein Chef kann
direkt wahrscheinlich gar nicht über dein Gehalt entscheiden, sondern muss dann seinen Chef machen.
Er kann das einfach auch nur gut, gut verkaufen und dementsprechend ist es wahrscheinlich besser,
du nimmst, du nimmst ein paar Punkte, die noch mehr mitbekommen haben, ja. Ja. Morgen beginnt
Ausbildung, good luck, have fun. Nee, die sind, glaube ich, immer noch bei, bei der, bei dieser
Aufsichtsbehörde von den Amis. Kubanetes oder, einheitlich Kubanetes. Nomad ist, das kenne ich,
das ist das von HashiCorp. Das ist aber noch weniger eine Kubanetes-Alternative, sondern mehr
so ein generelles Orchestrierungs-Ding für alle möglichen Sachen, nicht unbedingt rein für Container.
Wenn ich das richtig im Hinterkopf habe, nie was davon gemacht, aber generell würde ich eindeutig
Kubanetes sagen, wenn ich dazwischen die Auswahl hätte, weil du viel, viel mehr Leute findest,
die damit Expertise haben und das das bekanntere und verbreitete Produkt ist. Nein, haben wir nicht.
NettoLohn.de. Okay. Können wir klar machen. Ja, aber ich weiß mein Gehalt gerade nicht auf 100%,
das müsste ich dann vorher hochrechnen. Ja, also, so, ich bin jetzt unten angekommen. Also,
auf die Frage hin, doch, da ist Bonus drin, bei uns funktioniert das mit Bonus folgendermaßen,
wir bekommen Bonus anteilig ausbezahlt, also, wenn ich das jetzt richtig zusammenkriege,
ich bin mir da nicht 100%ig sicher, aber ich glaube, das ist so, wir bekommen Bonus anteilig
ausbezahlt pro Monat, allerdings nur den Mindestbonus, also die aller, aller unterste
Grenze, die du eh immer bekommen würdest, die kriegst du oben drauf. Also, wir haben,
wir haben Bonus von, das geht von irgendwie dem, es gibt, ich krieg's nicht, ich krieg's aus dem
Kopf nicht richtig zusammen, es gibt irgendwie, es gibt drei verschiedene Boni und die gehen von,
was weiß ich, 0,5 bis, also von mal 0,5 bis mal 2 oder sowas in der Richtung und was du monatlich
dazu bekommst, ist nur der Mindest, das Mindeste, was du minimal bekommen könntest, also dreimal,
dreimal 0,5 irgendwie noch, noch drauf und, und dann gibt es, dann gibt es einmal oder zwei,
also im April auf jeden Fall, einmal oder zweimal im Jahr dann die Bonusauszahlung für den Rest.
Also, wenn du mal angenommen, du hast deine persönlichen Ziele alle erreicht,
deine Abteilung war super gut, der Firma ging super gut und die sagen, hey, du kriegst jetzt
irgendwie 1,8 oder so bei allen drei Boni oder 1,5 und es schwankt ein bisschen 1,
0,1, 1, keine Ahnung, so und das kriegst du dann, glaube ich, Anteil, das kriegst du dann,
nicht Anteil, das kriegst du dann, glaube ich, im April und im Dezember oder so mit ausbezahlt.
So 100%ig komplett durchgestiegen bin ich noch nicht, also ja, das ist mit Bonus,
was ich euch vorgelesen habe, aber das ist nicht mit komplettem Bonus.
Bist du dir sicher, dass du als Softwareentwickler angestellt bist?
Nein, bin ich nicht, also ich, ich denke, als Einschießgehalt ist das richtig gut,
ich hatte ja mal, ich hatte ja mal ausgerechnet, mein Einschießgehalt heute wäre irgendwie 45k,
48k, so in dem Dreh, den du studiert hast, fände ich das hier durchaus, je nach,
je nach Region sicherlich okay.
Morgen zwei neue Azubis, einfach vier Anwendungsentwickler,
zwei Azubis auf zwei Vollzeitentwickler, ist doch gut, dann könnt ihr die gleich
ordentlich was schaffen lassen und ganz ehrlich, wenn ihr ordentliche Azubis habt,
man sollte Azubis nicht so sehr, ja, das auch, man sollte Azubis gar nicht so sehr als kostet
nur Zeit sehen, viele Azubis sind five headiger, als man denkt, es gibt auch,
es gibt auch Negativbeispiele, ja, aber gerade wenn man gute Azubis hat, sind die oftmals schlauer,
als man, als man so denkt, die kriegen auch richtig viel schon hin und das nach kurzer Zeit,
also es kann durchaus sein, dass eure Azubis euch auch viel helfen können.
Oh, wir hatten die Seite aufgemacht, man, tja, ONKS.
Hey, wenn ich Linus lernen möchte, welche Linus-Diskussion würdest du empfehlen und
welche vor allem ist deiner Meinung nach die beste?
Wenn du Linus lernen möchtest, tja, willst du nur ein bisschen Basics lernen oder willst du in
der Tiefe was lernen, wenn du in der Tiefe was lernen willst, dann Arch, by the way,
selbstverständlich, was sonst, weil Arch beste, best ever, wenn du allerdings noch gar keine Ahnung
von Linus hast und dich einfach ein bisschen einarbeiten willst und mal ein bisschen schauen
möchtest, ob das was für dich ist, dann würde ich sagen, nimm lieber Linus Mint oder vielleicht
auch ein Ubuntu oder sowas, ja, aber ansonsten Arch, by the way, beste, so, machen wir das mal
schnell, was soll berechnet werden, Stundenlohn, ihr Brutto, was hatte ich gesagt, 5.745 oder
irgendwie sowas, ne, Abrechnungszeit, wöchentliche Arbeitsstunden, wie viel habe ich denn Arbeitsstunden
wöchentlich, also wir haben keine 8 Stunden am Tag, wir haben irgendwie sowas Scheppes,
irgendwie 7,4 oder sowas am Tag, ja, 30 ungefähr, sagen wir mal 30, sagen wir mal 30, ich weiß nicht,
vielleicht sind es auch 31, es ist so ganz, ne, ne, es sind nicht 32, es ist so ganz Schepp,
es ist so ganz Schepp, hast du nicht auch 37,8, ja, das kann sein und 37,8 sind, 37,8 mal 0,8 sind,
kann das das nicht, 30, okay, das wird's, das wird's wahrscheinlich sein, okay, 38, ne, ja,
ja, doch, doch, 38 Stunden, also 7, dann war ich doch, dann war ich doch vorhin gar nicht schlecht,
ich habe gesagt, wir haben 7,35, ja, da war das doch vorhin gar nicht, gar nicht verkehrt,
was ich gesagt habe hier, 29,4, sagen wir mal 30, das ist einfacher zu rechnen, so, ihr Stunden,
ihr, das weiß ich nicht, das will ich doch ausrechnen, 44 Euro, okay, so sieht's, so schaut's
aus, Leute, wie kommen die jetzt da drauf und was war, und was war falsch an dem, was ich vorhin
berechnet habe, ach, das schwankt wahrscheinlich pro Monat, okay, ja, also 45 Euro irgendwie in dem
Dreh oder 44 Euro in dem Dreh, ja, ja, kommt hin, ich meine, realistisch betrachtet, wenn wir den
Bonus mitrechnen, das ist wahrscheinlich ein bisschen mehr, aber es geht, denke ich, ganz gut
in Ordnung, DevOps-Engineering oder Hybrid, ein Azubi ist top, der andere hat nette Ausgaben,
andere Qualitäten, aber ihr habt doch noch zwei andere, ihr habt doch vier jetzt, da hilft dem
Chat-GPT auch, komm, also, ich habe mich früher relativ viel um Azubis gekümmert, ja, und da
waren auch die einen oder anderen Planlosen dabei, aber selbst die Planlosen haben mittlerweile,
kriegen ganz gut was auf die Reihe, aber eine Sache habe ich auch gemerkt, manche brauchen
ein bisschen, die haben so ein bisschen Anlauf, die brauchen ein bisschen längeren Anlauf als
andere, ja, also es kann durchaus Azubis geben, da schlägst du die Hände über dem Kopf zusammen im
ersten halben Jahr oder im ersten Jahr, aber danach geht es, du hast natürlich auch den
umgetretenen Fall, welche, die von Anfang an nichts checken und bis zum Ende nichts checken
und bis zum Ende planlos sind, ja, und das, ach so, das Beste zum Virtualisieren, ja, an der Stelle
auch noch mal Forever Workstation hier, Beste, Forever Workstation, wenn es kostenlos sein soll,
dann geht Forever Player, wobei ich dir auch durchaus empfehlen kann, kauf dir Forever
Workstation mit einem Key bei einem Key-Shop, das kostet nur 5, 6, 7, 8 Euro und dann hast du die
beste Desktop-Virtualisierung-Software, da kannst du so machen wie ich, auf dem zweiten Desktop deine
Linux-Kiste, auf dem ersten Desktop dein Windows und dann kannst du zwischendrin hin und her
schalten und hast das Beste aus beiden Welten, so muss das sein, brauchte damals Anlauf, ja, ist so, das ist das,
was ich gerade gemeint habe, ja, nein, habe ich nicht, habe ich nicht, richtig, aber was man erwarten darf, ist,
wenn man schon mehrfach gezeigt hat, dass man dann nicht das fünfte Mal auch dabei sitzen muss, es
ist aber nicht schlimm, also ich finde, man merkt das schon relativ gut, wer da was, wer da was kann
und wer nicht und also ich hatte immer bei den Azubis, die ich es habe machen lassen, ein gutes Gefühl, ja,
also ich wusste genau, den kann ich allein ins Rechenzentrum schicken, der bricht sich jetzt nicht
das Bein oder reißt irgendwelche Kabel raus oder sowas oder den kann ich Zugang zu Produktivsystemen
geben für SSH, das wusste ich eigentlich und da ist, also ich kann mich jetzt an nichts erinnern,
das ist nie was passiert, ja, da sonst könnte ich mich daran erinnern, also bei manchen hatte ich ein gutes
Gefühl, da hat es auch immer ganz gut geklappt und bei manchen, wo ich sagen, gut, da habe ich dann
lieber zugeguckt, oh, was ist das, habe ich gerade übersehen, die Stadt Osnabrück sucht VCs oder was
ist hier los, hat jemand, hat jemand eben gepostet im Chat, richtig, ja, man merkt vor allem auch,
nicht nur, wer Bock hat, so, also, ja, rumgammelt, ganz ehrlich, jeder von uns gammelt mal ein bisschen rum,
wenn es natürlich welche sind, die gar keinen Bock haben, was zu lernen, manche brauchen auch einfach
nur das richtige Thema, ich weiß, dass dann die meisten Leute sagen, ja, aber Max, man kann sich
doch in später auch nicht aussuchen, was man will, ja, das stimmt, aber Ausbildung ist auch irgendwie ein
bisschen mit dafür da, dass man eben rauskriegt, was für Themen einem eben liegen und welche nicht,
also, wenn man beispielsweise keinen Bock hat auf Windows, kann ich das falsch verstehen, wenn man
den ganzen Tag nur rumgammelt, wenn man dann vielleicht in Linux-Team kommt und feststellt,
boah, das ist genau meins, da können die Leute schon wieder ganz anders aussehen, ja, und man
merkt halt auch, ob die Leute nicht nur, ja, nicht nur Bock haben, sondern auch so ein bisschen in
dem Element sind und es ist halt nicht bei allen immer alles gleich gut, also, ich musste beispielsweise,
wo ich beim Provider war, da wollten Leute auch, dass ich Windows-Automatisierung mache, habe ich,
ich will nicht sagen, dass ich es geweigert, in dem Sinn habe ich mich nicht, aber ich habe es halt
so schlecht gemacht, beziehungsweise so, so blöd gemacht, dass sie mich das nicht mehr machen lassen
wollten, ja, damals mussten wir in irgend so einem komischen Windows-Automatisierungstool, wo
Windows, also, wo du PXE, Windows-Server booten konntest, irgendwelche Boot-Automatisierung-Skripts
hinterlegen und das war so ein Rotz, Alter, ich habe die ganze Zeit dabei rumgemeckert und das
haben sie dann recht schnell gecheckt und dann habe ich eigentlich nur noch Linux-Sachen machen
lassen. Gab's da noch kein PowerShell? Gab's 2007? Gab's da PowerShell? Ja, gerade so, gerade so, gerade so.
Was wir damals benutzt haben war Altiris-Software-Verwaltung oder sowas, ja, sowas hier.
So in der Richtung sah das aus, nur noch oldschooliger damals, ganz ekliges Zeug, keine Ahnung,
warum man das verwenden sollte. Habe ich mich damit auch nie, danach nie wieder beschäftigt, geiler Name, oder?
Habe ich mich danach auch nie wieder beschäftigt, Windows-Administration und ich, wir werden nicht wahr
miteinander. Das war ja bei mir im Vorstellungsgespräch auch so. Ich wurde gefragt, Herr Max, was, das war
so eine typische HighIQ-Personaler-Frage. Wir haben gefragt, Herr Max, was müssten wir dann machen,
dass sie so richtig aufregt? Ja, und da hat er gedacht, so ich antworte jetzt sonst was drauf und
ich habe halt gesagt Windows-Administrieren. Und da meinte er so, ja, nee, nichts fachlich
bezogenes, eher so, so im täglichen Umgang oder irgendwie sowas, keine Ahnung. Ich weiß nicht mehr,
was ich dann darauf geantwortet habe, aber meine erste Antwort war Windows-Administrieren. Und das
ist so, ich habe keine Ahnung von Windows, ich will keine Ahnung von Windows haben und ich will mit
Windows auch nichts machen. Letztens haben sie auf der Arbeit schon erzählt, wir kriegen demnächst
MSSQL-Daten oder irgendjemand möchte an uns MSSQL-Datenbanken auf Windows übergeben. Da habe
ich auch gemeint, ja, das kann der gerne machen, nicht an mich. Tatsächlich, ja, habe ich gesagt,
richtig. Sagt mal, die Modkits wissen mehr, was ich in meinem Vorstellungsgespräch gesagt habe,
als ich selbst jetzt nach einem halben Jahr, fast einem halben Jahr. Also, was haben wir denn hier
zu bieten? IT-Mitarbeiter gesucht, Stadt Osnabrück. Okay, schauen wir mal, ob das was für uns wäre.
Sec. Übrigens, kleiner Sellout am Rande und heute geht es nicht um Prime Subs. Natürlich,
wer Prime Subs übrig hat und bald ist ja auch wieder der Erste, morgen ist es wieder soweit,
guckt darauf, dass ihr eure Prime Subs nicht verfallen lässt. Muss auch nicht an mich sein,
aber kleine Streamer freuen sich da besonders gerne drüber. Also, welche mit wirklich noch
noch weniger als ich habe. Ja, lasst sie bloß nicht verfallen, aber das ist gar nicht das,
was ich sagen wollte. Und zwar, wem das gefällt, was ich im Stream mache, gerade auch so Technik-Sachen,
die wir sonst eigentlich hauptsächlich machen, nicht unbedingt heute. Heute ist ja eher Laberstream.
Der kann mir natürlich auch gerne folgen auf Twitch. Ist ja auch eine Möglichkeit. Das heißt,
wenn ihr in Zukunft mit dabei sein wollt, könnt ihr jetzt an den Follow-Button drücken und das
kostet im Vergleich zu Prime Sub auch nichts. DJSW, dankeschön für den Sub. POG. Unser Krankenhaus
sucht noch einen EDV-Administrator. Oh ja, Krankenhausadministrator, das klingt nice. Ja,
aber dankeschön Leute, so mal rückwirkend für die ganzen Prime Subs. Ihr wisst, ich bin kein Mann
großer Worte, was Prime Sub und Subschreiben und so angeht. Gibt Leute, die können da viel mehr
eskalieren, so nach dem Motto, danke Leute, ohne euch wäre ich gar nichts und dann anfangen zu
weinen vor der Kamera. Das kriege ich nicht hin. Aber ich kann euch jetzt wirklich ehrlich was
sagen. Also eins finde ich wirklich mega nice. Ich sehe, es lohnt sich wirklich regelmäßig zu
streamen. Ich habe aktuell so viele Subs, wie ich noch nie hatte. Wahrscheinlich auch ein bisschen
die... Fuck, ich habe vergessen, wer es war. Irgendjemand hat letztens 40 Subs oder 25 Subs
gegiftet. Wahrscheinlich hat er da auch einen großen Anteil mit. Aber schön, dass letzterzeit
so viele Leute da sind und auch so viele Leute sich dafür entschieden haben, mich zu Prime
Subscriben. So, genug geschleimt, weiter geht's. Moin Farfi, doch Vollzeit Influencer. Ne, mache
ich nicht. Mich hat letztens auf der Arbeit jemand gefragt, Max, ich glaube das habe ich am Anfang des
Streams schon erzählt, am Anfang der Arbeit mich gefragt, Max, am Anfang des Streams erzählt, hat
mich auf der Arbeit gefragt, Max, warum copypastest du immer Einsen? Habe ich mein Screen geshared und
habe halt auch das gleiche gemacht wie hier. Max, warum copypastest du immer Einsen? Da wollte ich
fast darauf antworten. Ja, gebe Ausrufezeichen 1 im Chat ein, dann gibt es eine Erklärung. Cyberbeef, danke
für den Sub. Habe ich aber nicht gemacht. Ja, in den Keyshop, deiner Wahl. Ja, ist echt so. So, also was
wäre denn die Stadt Osnabrück? Zeigt mal her. IT-Mitarbeiter gesucht. Was haben sie denn da so zu
bieten? Applikationsmanager, Servicetechniker, DMS-Applikations, weiß ich nicht was. Storage oder so
was. Mitarbeiter, IT-Sicherheit. Da gucken wir uns doch mal an, was die Stadt Osnabrück, ups, Osnabrück zu
bieten hat. Modem-Geräusche, top aktuell. Alle super glücklich. Dokumentenmanagement-System.
Hi, ich bin Tobias. Wir sind hier bei der Stadt Osnabrück im Referat Digitalisierung und IT.
Die hätten das mal ein bisschen kompressoren müssen, das Video. Wir können das mal in höhere
Auflösung machen. So, jetzt. Hi, ich bin Tobias. Jetzt Tobias in High-Res. Wir sind hier bei der Stadt Osnabrück im Referat Digitalisierung und IT. Im Referat, das
hört sich für mich schon viel zu bürokratisch an. Gesamte IT bei der Stadt und begleiten unsere
Dienststellen auf dem Weg in die große Digitalisierung. Im Prinzip ist es eine sichere. Erstmal
Fax automatisieren. Stelle. Es fühlt sich schon alles sehr rund an. Nach der Ausbildung wollte
ich halt einen sicheren Job haben. Langweilig wird uns nie. Und die IT ist ja immer im Wandel. Das
Thema Flexibilität ist zum Glück groß geschrieben bei der Stadt. Das passt ganz gut zu mir. Das Thema
Flexibilität ist groß geschrieben. Jetzt würde mich nur noch interessieren, was verstehen die
denn da drunter? Es klang zwar ein bisschen auswendig gelernt, okay, aber... Das Thema Flexibilität ist zum
Glück groß geschrieben bei der Stadt. Das passt ganz gut zu mir. Wir sind hier echt schon Vorreiter. Familie, Freunde,
Beruf, das ist echt super. Wir haben flexibler Arbeitszeiten. Wir können das mit Homeoffice
kombinieren. Okay, wie hoch der Anteil? Passt sich sehr gut in meiner jeweiligen Lebenssituation an
und deswegen bin ich hier eigentlich auch schon 20 Jahre. Ja, die Kollegen waren halt... So alt sieht
die gar nicht aus. 20 Jahre? Krass. Ja. Na gut, dann wird ja die Ausbildung nicht vor 20 oder so gemacht haben.
Die Kollegen waren halt doch schon ein Grund, warum ich wieder zurück wollte. Gesamtpaket. Ach, er war schon mal
woanders, okay. IT ist ja immer durch den Technologiewandel. Bei uns ist das nicht klassische Behörde, sondern eher wirklich...
Also, also für 40 sieht die noch wirklich, wirklich gut aus. ...moderne Arbeitgeber. Es gibt Weiterbildungsmöglichkeiten.
Unsere Passion ist es, dass wir das digitale Bürgererlebnis in die Wohnzimmer der Osnabrücker und Osnabrückerinnen bringen.
Oh, Alter. In die Wohnzimmer der Osnabrücker und Osnabrückerinnen bringen. Die digitalisier... Das digitale Bürgererlebnis.
Ja gut, per Fax halt. ...in die Wohnzimmer der Osnabrücker und Osnabrückerinnen bringen. Wenn du ein Teil davon sein willst,
bewirb dich jetzt. Ich bin bei der Stadt. Wann bist du bei der Stadt? Ich arbeite bei der Stadt. Wann arbeitest du bei der Stadt?
Ich bin bei der Stadt. Wann bist du bei der Stadt? Coole Arbeitgeber. Kommt hier hin. Geile Sache. Fertig.
Hat Spaß hier. Ja, okay. Ganz ehrlich, besserer Spot, als ich gedacht hätte. Besserer Spot, als ich gedacht hätte.
Es kam ein bisschen wenig rum dabei, was denn jetzt so geil ist. Und vielleicht haben die auch einen Link da drauf irgendwo, okay.
Und warum die es so toll finden, aber weniger schlimmer, als ich gedacht habe. Ey, weniger schlimmer, als ich gedacht habe.
Ja, da will ich mir nichts von angucken. Ich wollte noch irgendwas zum Chat hier sagen. Wann bist du bei der Stadt?
Zwar... Gibt es den krassen Aufzug noch im Haus seines Opas? Nein, gibt es nicht mehr.
Ich wohne jetzt da. Falls du es nicht mitgekriegt hast. Also ich wohne dort in der Zwischenzeit.
Und ich sitze schräg gegenüber vom Aufzug. Gerade. Ist mein Arbeitszimmer. Aber der Aufzug ist nicht mehr da.
Ich wollte eben etwas sagen, habe ich aber verpeilt. Was ist das beste Jobportal? Keine Ahnung, was wirklich das beste ist.
Moment, Management System.
Ach, ich habe vergessen, was ich sagen wollte, Freund.
Matrix, danke für den Sub. Ja, Stepzone habe ich auch schon viel geguckt, aber ich weiß nicht, ob es wirklich die beste ist.
So, jetzt gucken wir uns schnell noch das an, weil wir haben nicht mehr so viel Zeit heute.
Also die Zeitsanzeige war gar nicht so übel, glaube ich. Ich weiß nicht, was ich da als Fazit...
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich da schon ein Fazit abgegeben habe. Ich glaube, die war gar nicht so schlecht.
Relax, danke für den Sub. Doch, die war eigentlich ganz gut, die Zeitsanzeige. Stimmt, ja.
Kennst du Informatiker, die wenig Geld verdienen? Stimmt.
Ich meine nur, Informatik studiert haben oder eine Ausbildung in dem Bereich gemacht haben, ist kein Garant dafür, dass du automatisch jetzt ultra viel Kohle verdienst.
First Level Support, ja, zum Beispiel. Wobei, da hast du Leute sitzen, die müssen auch nicht mal Ahnung von Technik haben.
Wie hat sich dein Gehalt in den ersten drei Jahren entwickelt? Boah, das weiß ich doch jetzt nicht mehr.
Also angefangen habe ich mit 33.500 und dann war ich ja nicht lange mehr bei dem Provider.
Dann habe ich gewechselt zur Bank in Frankfurt und da gab es eine ganze Ecke mehr Geld.
Also ich glaube, es war so. Ich glaube, ich habe mit 33.500 angefangen.
Dann gab es nach einer Weile beim Provider noch irgendwie um 36.000 Euro.
Und dann bin ich zur Bank gewechselt und damals bei einer Bank gab es, glaube ich, auch schon 50.000 Euro.
Irgendwie so. Ich weiß es nicht mehr genau.
Das war aber noch im Tarifvertrag und dann hat sich das die Jahre über ein bisschen gesteigert.
Dann bin ich den viel zu lange nicht auf den Keks gegangen, dass ich mehr Geld haben will.
Bis ich das dann irgendwann mal gecheckt habe, dass es sinnvoll ist, öfters mal zu nerven wegen mehr Geld.
Da gab es dann auch ein paar mal mehr Geld und dann hatte ich irgendwann 76.000, erst 70.000, dann 76.000.
Dann gab es nochmal ein bisschen was obendrauf und dann bin ich gewechselt.
Ich kann euch gar nicht das aller allerletzte Gehalt bei der Bank sagen.
Müsste wahrscheinlich irgendwas um 80k++ Bonusdinger gewesen sein.
Ne, weniger. Mit Bonus. Ja doch, mit Bonus vielleicht.
Mit sehr viel Wohlwollen.
Ja, bei mir gab es auch eine ganze Ecke mehr, wo ich gewechselt bin.
Ich glaube ganz so viel ist es bei mir nicht.
Wie viel Prozent sind denn das?
80k auf so 100. Tja, ist halt die Frage, wie viel es jetzt am Ende wirklich ist, wie es mit dem Bonus aussieht.
Sagen wir mal so 100, 110k. Was ist denn das? Wie viel Prozent ist das?
Na doch, doch, doch, auch ungefähr so.
Ja, ja doch.
Ja, das sind 30, 30k. Das sind so 25, 25, 30%. Ne, sind ja sogar ein bisschen mehr.
Eher so 110. Also es schwankt. Minimum sind 95k und mit allen Boni und so sind es dann irgendwie 115k.
Also realistisch betrachtet ist es irgendwas um 110 oder sowas.
Ja, so auch 30% so in dem Dreh.
Ja, das war meine Gehaltsentwicklung über ungefähr 16 Jahre IT inklusive Ausbildung.
So, was haben wir denn hier zu bieten?
DevOps, Engineer, MWD, Remote oder Hybrid?
Also ich kann euch nur eine Sache empfehlen Leute.
Guckt, wenn es euch wirklich ein bisschen auf den Keks geht bei euch auf der Arbeit.
Oder selbst, selbst wenn ihr einfach nur wissen wollt, wie viel denn eure Skills woanders wert sind.
Guckt euch einfach ein bisschen um.
Ich sag nicht mal, dass es irgendwie, muss ich jetzt vielleicht an der Stelle auch sagen.
Es ist ja nicht mal unbedingt gerechtfertigt in dem Sinn, dass man jetzt sagt.
Hey, als ITler verdient man so viel, als Elektroniker verdient man so schlecht.
Aber ganz im Ernst, wenn einer zu euch kommen würde und sagt.
Hey, wollt ihr 15k mehr im Jahr? Wird auch keiner nein sagen.
Es ist aktuell echt so ein bisschen Angebot und Nachfrage.
Und solange ihr in der guten Situation seid, dass ihr das machen könnt.
Wenn ihr einfach nur mal feststellen wollt, hey was sind denn eure Skills so wert?
Guckt euch mal ein bisschen um.
Es zwingt euch keiner wirklich zu unterschreiben oder dahin zu fahren oder irgendwelche Dinger zu machen.
Ihr könnt jederzeit aus dem Bewerbungsprozess wieder aussteigen und es passiert euch nichts.
Aber mal so ein bisschen vorführen und ein bisschen gucken, hat auch noch einen weiteren riesen Vorteil.
Oder zwei große Vorteile.
Erstens, vielleicht findet man ja wirklich was, was einen auf ganzer Ebene überzeugt.
Also wo man sagt, hey die Kombination aus Geld, aus Homeoffice, aus weiteren Benefits.
Was weiß ich, Kindergarten, wenn ihr Kinder habt, was auch immer, was die bieten.
Plus die Leute, die ich da kennengelernt habe.
Finde ich so toll, dass ich das doch machen will. Kann auch sein.
Also ihr könnt ja im Endeffekt nur gewinnen.
Oder, wenn das halt nichts ist und ihr gar keinen Bock habt, dann die Bewerbung weiter durchzusehen.
Habt ihr zumindest gelernt, was eure Skills so Pima Daumen grob wert sind.
Was euch vielleicht auch eine ganze Ecke mehr Selbstsicherheit gibt für die nächste Gehaltsverhandlung.
Weil, ich hab das bei mir gemerkt, früher, ich hab mich bei sowas immer nicht getraut eine Zahl zu sagen.
Weil ich immer gedacht hab, oh alles ist zu viel.
Nein, das stimmt nicht.
Man sollte sich nicht da selbst schlechter reden als man ist.
Was natürlich einfacher fällt, wenn man eben weiß, was für die Skills so bezahlt wird drumherum.
Wenn ihr jetzt denkt, kann ich jetzt 10% mehr fordern, kann ich 15, wie auch immer, was kann ich denn so machen.
Es fällt bestimmt vielen leichter, wenn sie mal eine Zahl gehört haben, auch von außerhalb der Firma, wo sie jetzt arbeiten.
Das unterstreicht das Ganze noch ein bisschen mehr.
Mal angenommen, ihr verdient jetzt einen Betrag x.
Ihr verdient in 60k.
Und euer Chef sagt euch, aktuell so Wirtschaft schlecht und davor war ja noch Corona.
Und ihr seid prinzipiell immer am jammern, wenn es um mehr Geld geht.
Da können wir maximal 5% machen oder so, wenn überhaupt, eigentlich können wir gar nichts machen.
Und wenn ihr dann genau wisst, hier um die Ecke, wenn ihr da jetzt anfangen würdet,
selbst wenn es euch da gar nicht so gut gefällt, dass ihr da wirklich anfangen würdet,
aber wenn ihr rausbekommen habt, hey, die würden mir da einfach 20% mehr bezahlen,
ergibt das eine gewisse innere Ruhe für solche Gespräche.
Zu sagen, mit 5% bin ich aber nicht zufrieden.
Natürlich muss man das trotzdem gut verkaufen können.
Einfach nur sagen, gib mir mehr oder ich hau ab, ist keine gute Idee, wenn man da bleiben will zumindest.
Weil dann kann es durchaus sein, dass sie sagen, ja gut, dann mach es halt gut.
Also ordentlich begründen muss man das Ganze schon.
Und deswegen ist es natürlich gut, man hat in der Vergangenheit coole Sachen gemacht
und auch ein bisschen drüber geredet, dass man coole Sachen gemacht hat.
Dass es nicht nur dein Chef mitbekommen hat, sondern vielleicht auch der Chef oben drüber.
Und wenn dein Chef einen guten Job macht, dann verkauft er ja auch die Sachen, die sein Team macht, ganz gut nach oben weiter.
Und dann kannst du die da schön auf den Tisch legen, kannst sagen, guck mal das, das, das.
Hat die Firma enorm weitergebracht, hat vieles in dem und dem Bereich bewirkt.
Hast dir auch was von gehört.
Und wenn dein Chef dann zu seinem Chef geht, der das unterschreiben muss,
wenn der die Dinge auch schon gehört hat, dann hast du natürlich eine ganz andere Position.
Dann sagst du, ach ja, das ist der, der, der und der, ja der, das ist ein guter Mann.
Es kann natürlich auch trotzdem sein, dass die sagen, ach ne, hier einmal kein Bock, mehr Geld gibt's nicht.
Gut, am Schluss muss man sich immer denken, ja, ist es hier so geil, dass ich auch mit weniger da bleiben will?
Oder würde ich sagen, ok, es gibt aktuell in jeder Ecke Jobs für IT-Fachkräfte, guck ich mir doch mal ein bisschen ernster die Sachen an.
Und finde vielleicht was, was in allen Belangen besser ist und mehr Kohle bringt.
Ja, das würde ich auch nicht, also spätestens, also ich würde auf gar keinen Fall sagen so nach dem Motto,
gib mir Geld oder ich hau ab, wenn ich es nicht ernst meine.
Wenn man es ernst meint, also, wenn man es ernst meint, kann man es vielleicht probieren.
Ich habe beim alten Arbeitgeber das ähnlich gemacht, allerdings bei mir war das kein Gepokere in dem Sinn,
sondern ich hatte wirklich keinen Bock mehr.
Ich habe das meinem Chef ja schon vor einer Weile gesagt, hier also, es gibt ein paar Sachen, die gehen mir wirklich auf den Keks.
Ich gucke mich um und da hat er gemeint, ja, wenn es konkret wird, dann sag nochmal Bescheid.
Da habe ich ihm Bescheid gesagt, als es konkret geworden ist.
Und die haben sich immer noch rumgedingst mit, ah, mehr Homeoffice geht nicht und hier ein schlechtes Jahr und so.
Und da habe ich gesagt, wisst ihr was, dann nicht.
Und das war jetzt im Nachhinein, so nach vier Monaten, kann ich sagen, war die richtige Entscheidung.
Wie viel RAM ich, äh, wie viel RAM? Ne, wie viele Tabs ich offen habe? Boah, weiß ich nicht.
120 oder so? Ah, nicht ganz, 100?
Ersten Zehnten geht's los, nice.
Ja, klingt auch gut, klingt auch gut.
Das wird dir sicherlich nicht zum Verhängnis werden.
Also, ich habe es noch nie erlebt, gut, ist jetzt auch nicht so, als habe ich schon tausende Bewerbungen, Vorstellungsgespräche und Gehaltsverhandlungen gemacht.
Aber ich habe es auch noch nie gehört, dass es irgendeinem zum Verhängnis geworden ist, weil er mal mehr Geld verlangt hat.
Also es wäre ja auch letztendlich irgendwo dämlich.
Versetzt euch doch mal in die andere Seite rein.
Ihr sitzt in einem Vorstellungsgespräch und ihr habt einen Kandidaten vor euch.
Der macht einen super Eindruck und ihr denkt, das passt, den würdet ihr gerne einstellen.
Und dann fragt ihr den, okay, was haben sie sich so vorgestellt?
Und der sagt dann 60k, so.
Und Personalabteilung und Führungsriege und alle sagen, ja, mehr als, keine Ahnung, 52k können wir dem Typ nicht bezahlen für die Position.
Ja, gut.
Dann werden die sicherlich nicht sagen, ah, sie wollen 60k?
Ähm, ja, hier ist die Tür.
Warum sollten sie das machen?
Du bist doch immer noch ein guter Kandidat dafür.
Ja, da werden sie wahrscheinlich sagen, so, ah, hm, passt bei uns jetzt nicht so ganz ins Gehaltsgefüge oder irgendwie Blödsinn, werden sie sich ausdenken.
Und dann vielleicht mal ein Gegenangebot, weil am Ende einigt ihr euch vielleicht bei 54k oder so.
Also, das habe ich noch nie gehört, dass das irgendeinem zum Verhängnis geworden ist.
Ich meine, wenn du jetzt sagst, also mal angenommen, die haben eine Vorstellung von, sie wollen da maximal 52k bezahlen.
Und du sagst dann, was haben sie für eine Vorstellung?
Und du sagst dann 1,5 Millionen, dann werden sie wahrscheinlich lachen und das nicht ernst nehmen.
Oder wenn du sagst, 250k und die merken, dass du es ernst meinst, dann werden sie vielleicht sagen, oh ne, das ist dann doch weit über dem, was wir uns hier vorgestellt haben.
Dann weiß ich nicht, wie sie reagieren.
Aber wenn man einen guten Kandidat vor sich hat, der wird ja nicht automatisch zu einem schlechten Kandidat, weil er eine Ecke drüber liegt in dem, was er sich vorstellt.
Das heißt ja nicht umsonst Gehaltsverhandlungen.
Das weiß ich nicht.
Wie gesagt, das kann man pauschal so auch nicht sagen.
Es kommt auf die Branche an, es kommt auf die Region an, es kommt ein bisschen darauf an, was man macht.
Das ist, du kannst dir Statistiken angucken.
Ja, da gab es letztens erst wieder bei Heise irgendeine Umfrage.
Du kannst dir bei Stackoverflow die Umfrage, die Stackoverflow Umfrage ist eher, aber eher so Ami-mäßig geprägt.
Da gibt es Umfragen, Statistiken, so kannst du gucken, wie das im Durchschnitt ist.
Pauschal ist es schwierig.
Wie gesagt, ich bin kein wandelndes Gehaltslexikon oder so.
Ich kann euch sagen, also ich kann euch sicher sagen, was man bekommt in der Frankfurter Finanzbranche mit 15 Jahren plus Berufserfahrung.
Ich kann euch auch den Verlauf dahin sagen, so.
Ich kann euch nicht sagen, wie sieht es aus bei irgendeinem mittelständischen Laden auf dem Land im Osten.
Keine Ahnung.
Weiß ich nicht.
Ja, das stimmt.
Ich habe bestimmt acht oder so anrufen müssen, bis ich einen gefunden habe, der mir das Ladegerät fürs Elektroauto daheim installiert.
Ich gehe auch davon aus, dass die die nächsten Jahre über auch alle noch preislich anziehen werden und auch ihre Leute noch besser bezahlen müssen.
Weil ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass es handwerklich da ähnliche Probleme gibt.
Es gibt viele Unternehmen, die ganz viele Handwerksexperten suchen und die, die keine finden, müssen halt gucken, was sie machen.
Also denen bleibt ja im Endeffekt nur übrig, sich selbst attraktiver machen, unter anderem durch mehr Gehalt oder ihre Ansprüche runterschrauben.
Und Ansprüche kannst du auch nur, wenn du eine gescheite Arbeit verrichtet hast, unter ein gewisses Niveau runterschrauben.
Also bleibt dir im Endeffekt nichts übrig, wie gute Arbeitsbedingungen bieten und das auch so zu verkaufen und ordentlich Gehalt zu bezahlen.
Also da wird es dort die nächsten Jahre und aktuell auch schon anziehen.
Im Handwerker gibt es krasse Preise beim Endkunden.
Ja gut, aber es wird sich ja früher oder später durchschlagen müssen, wenn die Unternehmen keine Leute mehr finden.
Sobald es da eng wird und die keine Leute mehr finden, was sollen die machen außer mehr zu bezahlen?
Außer weiter keine Leute finden.
Also ich kann dir keinen Support für VMware Keys hier im Chat geben.
Die einzig offizielle Variante ist es, bei VMware zu kaufen.
Du wirst es schon hinbekommen, ein VMware Key zu finden.
Ja, dann gibt es halt kacke Arbeit.
Dann kommt halt Mist dabei raus.
Aber für Mist sind wahrscheinlich die meisten Kunden dann nicht bereit, viel Geld zu bezahlen.
Also ich habe gar keine Schmerzen mit.
Also ich bezahle auch ordentlich was.
Ich habe zum Beispiel einen Elektriker, der hier schon öfter Sachen gemacht hat, den würde ich auch wieder nehmen.
Oder ein paar andere. Da bin ich auch durchaus bereit für ordentlich was zu bezahlen.
Was ich nicht will ist, ordentlich bezahlen und scheiß Arbeit bekommen.
Ja.
Zum Beispiel, also eine Sache, wo ich gleich gesagt habe, das mache ich nicht.
Ich habe ja bestimmt, ich habe ja bei 7, 8 Elektrikern angerufen, ob die mir mein Ladegerät fürs Elektroauto installieren können.
So. Und die hatten alle keine Zeit, die hatten alle ewig, ewig lange Aufträge und so.
Und teilweise Monate warten.
Und da habe ich bei einem hier angerufen und der meinte, macht ihr sowas?
Und da meinte ich, ja das wäre möglich.
Und da habe ich gesagt, wie sieht das preislich so aus und wie machen sie das so?
Und da meinte er, ho, das wird kosten.
Und da habe ich mir auch schon gedacht, das klang jetzt nicht so seriös für mich.
Wahrscheinlich hätten die das in irgendeiner Nacht-und-Nebel-Aktion installiert, aber wer weiß, was da qualitativ rausgekommen wäre.
Das klang eher nach so, wir können das morgen machen, aber das wird kosten.
Aber wir schreiben auch keine Rechnung.
Also das ist was, wo ich mir gedacht habe, das muss nicht sein.
Dann bezahle ich lieber, das darf ruhig kosten.
Aber ich muss auch den Eindruck haben, dass gute Arbeit gemacht wird.
Und auch wenn ich mir angucke, muss da halt was Gescheites bei rauskommen.
Dann bezahle ich ordentlich was für.
Welches Auto hast du denn? Fiat 500e?
Besser. Würde ich mir wieder kaufen.
Für mein Fahrverhalten ist der Fiat genau das Beste.
Ich fahre damit nur einkaufen und hier ein bisschen im Umkreis von paar...
Das ist das meiste, was ich fahre.
Irgendwie 30, 30 Kilometer, 30, 40 Kilometer oder so.
Mal irgendwo ins Gelände, in die Berge, Berge darf man hier, weil die Schweizer Anwesen, Österreicher Anwesen sind, nicht sagen.
Ins Gelände, so Richtung Spessart und so mal ein bisschen in die Hügel.
Mach da halt meine tägliche eineinhalb, zwei Stunden Sport.
Dann fahre ich wieder zurück.
Also für mein Fahrverhalten ist der Fiat Bock.
Und ich würde es genauso wieder kaufen als Autos.
Das Einzige, das Einzige, was ich tatsächlich machen würde ist, wobei das ließ sich ja nicht ändern.
Ich habe ja so ein Vorführauto genommen, weil es da war und billiger war.
Also ein bisschen mehr Technik Sachen könnten es noch sein, die der Fiat eigentlich hat, aber das Vorführauto nicht hatte.
Aber ansonsten bin ich damit sehr, sehr zufrieden.
Sind es auch, sind es.
Kassettenlaufwerk? Nee, okay, konkret, konkret.
Was ich gerne hätte, ist zum Beispiel eine Rückfahrkamera.
Ich habe eine Rückfahrsensorin.
Ja, genau das.
Normalerweise hat der Fiat 500e eine Rückfahrkamera.
Aber das Vorführmodell hatte keine.
Und andere, wenn ich den, wenn ich den bestellt hätte, hätte das ewig gedauert.
Also habe ich den genommen. Das war auch relativ günstig.
Ich kann euch jetzt nicht mehr sagen, was es gekostet hat.
Chat weiß es bestimmt, ich habe es euch erzählt damals.
So und insgesamt finde ich das Auto wirklich nice.
Auch die Technik, die verbaut ist, wurde ja hier im Vorfeld, habe ich die Leute im Chat ja gewarnt.
Max, kauf dir bloß keinen Fiat, kauf dir gleich einen Tesla oder sowas.
Alter, wozu soll ich mir einen Tesla kaufen für meine 5 Minuten, die ich da jeden Tag rumfahre?
Chat, wieder am chatten gewesen.
Und da haben die mir Leute ja abgeraten von Max, kauf dir keinen Fiat, scheiß Technik und so.
Also es gibt ein paar Sachen, die wären vielleicht bei einem Tesla besser.
Dafür kostet ein Tesla auch das Dreifache.
Also eine Sache, die zum Beispiel ein bisschen doof ist, wo ich vermute, dass die beim Tesla besser ist.
Und zwar ist, dass man die Sachen ordentlich updaten kann.
Beim Fiat kannst du nur das Entertainment System updaten.
OTA, die anderen Sachen müssen in der Werkstatt gemacht werden.
Und das Entertainment System muss dann auch von den Versionen dazu passen.
Dementsprechend kannst du nur in einem gewissen Update-Rahmen das updaten und so.
Aber es ist eh nicht so, als gäbe es da viel.
Mal ganz davon abgesehen, von dem Entertainment System im Auto benutze ich genau eine Sache öfters.
Und das ist halt Carplay.
Den Rest benutze ich für das Handy.
Handy für Musik, Handy für Navigation.
Musik habe ich auch nicht oft an.
So, fertig, mehr brauche ich nicht.
Und was ich halt ansonsten noch auf dem Entertainment System mache, auf dem Dashboard,
ist halt so Dinger wie Klimaanlage einstellen, Temperatur und so was.
Wobei es dafür auch Knöpfe hat.
Der kleinste Tesla ist sogar für Tesla noch relativ günstig.
Oder meinst du den Fiat?
Der Fiat kostet auch so in dem Dreh.
Aber wie gesagt, ich glaube, ich habe...
Also wie gesagt, ich habe so ein Vorführmodell-Auto,
was halt schon ein bisschen rumgefahren ist.
Für Probefahrten.
Und ich glaube, ich habe 23.500 Euro bezahlt.
Für das Auto.
So, ich habe es euch damals erzählt.
Ich glaube 23.500.
Und muss ich ehrlich sagen, ich würde mir das Ding jederzeit wieder kaufen.
Der 500e ist ein richtig nices Auto.
Man muss natürlich erstmal ein bisschen dran gewöhnen.
Gerade, dass man keine Kupplung mehr hat.
Und auch keinen Knüppel.
Sondern, dass alles automatisch...
Was heißt ja automatisch?
Es geht ja noch nicht mehr automatisch.
Es gibt schlicht und ergreifend keine Gangschaltung mehr,
die da irgendwie automatisch gehen müsste.
Es gibt eine Gangschaltung.
Aber die Gangschaltung ist eigentlich nur
vorwärts, rückwärts, parken und Leerlauf.
Welche Farben hat ein Auto? Blau.
Aber die E-Auto-Anfrage geht zur Zeit stark zurück.
Ja, verstehe ich.
Letztes Jahr gab es ja auch noch richtig fette Förderung.
Die ist jetzt ja weniger.
Mal schauen.
Ich meine...
Ich hänge da nicht unbedingt dran.
Also sollte sich die nächsten Jahre
über was anderes durchsetzen.
Wovon ich ehrlich gesagt nicht ausgehe.
Weil, ganz ehrlich,
es wird jetzt an allen Ecken und Enden
Ladeinfrastruktur ausgebaut.
Nochmal eine andere Technik wäre jetzt echt schon ziemlich pepega.
Aber mal gucken.
Mal gucken, wie sich das entwickelt.
Ich meine, ich bin jetzt da nicht unbedingt
festgenagelt auf ein Elektroauto.
Den werde ich jetzt erstmal eine Weile fahren.
Gucken, wie lang.
Sicherlich nicht so lang wie mein alten Agila.
Du meinst...
Irgendwas mit S heißt das.
Irgendwas mit S.
Ich hab vergessen, wie es heißt.
Ich weiß, wo man es einstellt.
Da ist so ein Drehknopf bei mir in der Mitte.
In der Konsole.
Ähm, ja.
Hat der, hat der, ja.
Also der hat nicht verschiedene Modi,
wie stark er abbremst und Energie zurückgewinkt.
Er hat nur ein Modo.
Ja, aber bei Fiat heißt das anders.
Irgendwas mit S am Anfang.
Also der hat auch einen Modus, wo du einstellen kannst,
dass du automatisch
abbremst
und dadurch Energie
zurückgewinst.
Das wird dann verkauft so als
One Pedal Driving und solche
Geschichten.
Fiat nennt das irgendwie anders.
Irgendwas mit S
am Anfang heißt das.
Und...
Ja.
Da muss ich aber ehrlich sagen, das sollte ich
vielleicht öfters mal verwenden.
Ich benutze das relativ selten.
Nein, nein, nein, okay.
Wie heißt denn das?
Ah, da war es doch.
Hier.
Sherpa Modus heißt das.
Sherpa Modus.
Das ist ein Kackwort.
Das kann sich doch niemand merken.
Ich habe es wieder vergessen.
Sherpa Modus, genau das meine ich.
Ja, also
das sollte ich wahrscheinlich öfters
verwenden, mache ich aber nicht so oft.
So, genug Autotalk.
Ihr wisst, das ist eigentlich nicht so mein Thema.
Aber wie gesagt, ich würde den Fiat 500E
jederzeit wieder kaufen.
Das ist genau das richtige Auto für mich.
Passt top.
Und eins ist halt an dem auch nice.
Im Vergleich zu meinem alten...
Also wer es nicht weiß, was ich vorher für ein Auto
hatte, glaubt mir, der 500E
ist ein riesen Upgrade dazu.
Ich hatte davor
so einen.
In grün.
So, und dieses Ding hat gefühlt
null Beschleunigung gehabt.
Das hat rückwärts beschleunigt.
Also da
musstest du das Gaspedal gefühlt
bis hier vorne
in die
Scheinwerfer durchdrücken.
Hier vorne.
Dass das Ding überhaupt irgendwo dran
vorbeigekommen ist.
Hast du den fett getuned?
Ich hab nix an meinem Auto getuned.
Hauptsache agil.
Könnt ihr euch vorstellen?
Das Upgrade
von einem 2001er Opel
Agila. Und das war er auch noch.
Den Opel Agila gab es in zwei verschiedenen
Ausführungen. Einmal mit
einem stärkeren Motor und einmal
den, den ich hatte.
Und meiner, der hat wirklich
gar keine Beschleunigung.
Ich weiß nicht, ob man irgendwie technische Daten
hier, da...
Hier, technische Daten.
Zeigt mal her.
75 PS?
Gab's den auch noch mit 60?
Wenn es einen mit 60 gab, dann hatte ich
den.
Hier.
58 PS.
Da kecken die meisten Leute sich
wahrscheinlich komplett weg dabei hier.
60. Oder vielleicht hatte ich
auch den. Weiß ich nicht.
Ja, 58 oder
60. Also, der hatte nix.
Der hatte gar nix.
Gibt es... Ich bin mir gar nicht sicher,
ob es Info gibt, wie viel
der von 0 auf 100 gebraucht hat.
Ich würde sagen,
also reingefühlt
hat der Agila von 0 auf 100
so ungefähr 18 Sekunden gebraucht.
Oder länger.
Der ist gar nicht... Noch länger.
25. Der hat eine halbe Minute gebraucht,
bis der auf 100 war.
Echt, stand da? Wirklich? Wo?
Ach, hier.
Ja, aber so wie ich gefahren bin,
hat er bestimmt eine halbe Minute gebraucht.
Und was bei dem Fiat
halt extrem nice ist,
also nicht nur die Beschleunigung von 0 auf
100, das ist aber gar nicht das Ding.
Die Beschleunigung von 0 auf 70.
So, was du meistens brauchst,
auch wenn du kürzere Strecken fährst,
von Ampel zu Ampel irgendwo.
Leute, 0 auf 50, 0 auf 70,
das Ding ist die übelste Rakete, Alter.
Das flutscht wie sonst was.
Ich stelle mich jetzt sogar manchmal schon immer,
das ist wahrscheinlich so typisch
Boomer-Rentner-Fährt-Auto-Verhalten,
aber
also könnte ich mir gut
vorstellen, dass das andere Leute
auch so machen.
Das ist so ein typisches Opa-Verhalten.
Und zwar, ich stelle mich
jetzt sogar manchmal schon bei der Ampel
auf die linke Seite,
wenn ich sehe, dass vor mir
irgendwelche fetten BMW und
Mercedes und sowas stehen.
Und dann überhole ich die alle von 0 auf 70.
Danach
könnten die mich wahrscheinlich
easy
vorbeidüsen.
Aber von 0 auf 70 überholt mich so schnell
keiner mit meinem Fiat.
Das konnte ich mit dem Agila nicht machen, das konntest du vergessen.
Ja, Berg hochfahren,
das ging mit dem Agila, aber da hatte ich immer Angst,
dass der ausgeht und ich ihn nicht wieder ankriege.
Oder dass der quasi ausgeht und ich
hol aus Versehen rückwärts ein Stück.
Berge hochfahren mit dem Agila, das konntest du vergessen.
Gut, Leute,
ich muss ins Bett.
Wir sehen uns die Tage, macht's gut.
Bis dann, see you.